[Musique]
Loï le flog pronon. Bonsoir.
Bonsoir.
Nous vous recevons pour une chaîne
internet qui s'appelle Syerview. Nous
sommes en direct. Est-ce que vous pouvez
vous présenter succintement ? Je suis
euh Loï le FLOC Prentel
euh originaire de des côtes d'armor en
Bretagne.
J'ai été successivement président de
grande société et puis de plus petite.
Aujourd'hui, je suis président de
4 ou c PMI
industriel dans la mécanique métallurgie
et je suis en même temps président de de
la branche industrie de du mouvement
éthique, un mouvement qui
rassemble des entreprises de tout bord,
de toute origine
pour essayer de faire avancer la vie des
entreprises. prise en France, ce qui est
une
un problème en soi. Voilà,
on a décidé de vous faire venir
aujourd'hui parce que vous êtes un vieux
loup de mer de l'industrie. Vous avez
piloté des grosses boîtes énergétiques
françaises
et comme vous pouvez le voir, la France
est en train de calencher auprès de ces
entreprises. Elle est en train de
boîter, je dirais et et on a besoin de
vos lumières.
Comment vous percevez la situation ?
Comment vous percevez la la situation
énergétique de la France ? Quelle
répercussion ça va avoir sur nos boîtes
? Quelle répercussion ça va avoir sur le
tissu industriel français à court, moyen
et long terme ? Alors, la situation est
pour moi un drame, un drame personnel
parce que j'ai consacré ma vie euh
professionnelle, ma vie tout court à
l'industrie française et à l'énergie
puisque j'étais successivement président
euh de Elpaquitaen et de Gaz de France
euh que j'ai par ailleurs été président
de l'industrie chimique puis à travers
tout ça, l'industrie pharmaceutique et
je vois les dégâts qui ont été faits
déjà depuis des années par
méconnaissance ou par hostilité, on
finit par se demander si c'est pas
l'hostilité à l'égard de l'industrie et
là c'est une sorte de coup de grâce
c'est-à-dire que on a maltraité
le
l'indépendance énergétique de la France
qui était quasiment réalisé
il y a il y a 20 ans. Et puis on est en
train de
conduire l'industrie française au
désastre puisque les industriels de
toutes les de tous les pays adjacents
vont payer leur électricité trois fois
moins cher que nous industriel français
alors que notre électricité
est produite deux fois moins cher que
chez eux. C'est un drame, un drame sur
lequel visiblement
euh un certain nombre de gens se penche
mais en disant qu'ils n'y peuvent rien.
Euh que un drame que qui ne conduit pas
le patronat français à s'élever en
disant c'est pas supportable, il faut
que ça cesse. et on fait une conférence
de presse au bout de 6 mois alors qu'on
sait que le le la catastrophe est à nos
portes et c'est un drame parce queon
continue à parler d'autres choses.
C'estàdire que soudain on s'aperçoit
qu'il y a un chèque qui arrive pour le
pour X Y ou Z. Il y a un préservatif qui
gratuit. qui a
sans s'apercevoir de de la situation
de des emprises françaises qui a priori
euh si on regarde un peu les PGE,
c'est-à-dire les les prêts qui vont
disparaître à la fin de l'année et les
contrats qui vont commencer le 1er
janvier 2023, c'est de l'ordre de 300000
entreprises qui sont en dépôt de bilan
potentiel à partir du 1er janvier.
C'est c'est pas rien hein. Alors c'est
et on sait que les PME et les PMI et
tout ce tissu industriel français c'est
l'essentiel de l'emploi industriel. Donc
donc on d'un côté on dit je vais aider
les consommateurs et de l'autre on
oublie que ces consommateurs peuvent
travailler dans des entreprises qui vont
disparaître hein. Donc donc on est
on est on est des consommateurs
d'ailleurs avec notre fric.
Mais oui
c'est le chéquier de Mami France. Oui,
c'est ça. C'est ça. Effectivement euh on
a le sentiment que on emprunte dans des
conditions catastrophique. C'estàd que
on est à 150 milliards de déficit
commercial. On a eu un endettement qu'on
a jamais eu euh
et l'end l'endettement à Bissal, le
commerce commercial Bissal. On continue
à avoir de l'argent gratuit puisque
c'est d'autres qui payent. On sait pas
lesquels, on vous le donne parce que
vous êtes gentils, parce que vous faites
c, vous faites ça. Le le comble pour
moi, ça a été les boulangers. Les
boulangers, il vous expliquent très très
bien. Voilà, je suis aujourd'hui avec
une baguette à 1,20 €. Il faudrait pour
que je m'en sorte 1,70 €. Passer de 1,20
€ à 1,70 € le 1er janvier. Comment
comment c'est possible ? Hein ? Les tous
les clients vont hurler. Euh donc je
veux pas se b mais de toute façon je
peux pas continuer. Et puis vous
entendez euh le ministre qui dit "Bah
oui, c'est simple, on a bien compris, le
boulanger, il va passer de euh 50 euh
50000 € à 300000 € d'électricité. Oui,
c'est bien parce qu'il a des fours,
c'est normal. Bon, mais alors qui
s'inquiète pas ? qui s'inquiète pas
parce qu'on va lui donner un peu
d'argent. Euh bon, il va recevoir un
chèque de 200 € tout de suite hein dès
que dès qu'il
c'est pas c'est pas dans ces proportions
là. C'est par exemple euh euh on passe à
à je me je demande la communauté à mef
checker. On est à environ 15000 € de
fonctionnement pour un petit boulanger
qui a 10 employés ça passe à 80000 et il
va recevoir 8000 € de d'aide. C'est ça.
C'est ça.
Dans c dans ces eau là
s'il est gentil pour
c'est dire dans un premier temps soit
200 € après il reçoit 600 € ensuite s'il
fait un dossier il reçoit ça. C'est par
étape. Par étape. C'est c'est mais et ça
c'est complètement idiot. C'estàd que
c'estàd que on ne peut pas on ne peut
pas continuer à penser que les gens
travaillent pour recevoir des aides. On
on travaille parce que on aime le
travail parce que on a fait une
entreprise parce qu'on bâtit une
entreprise et on a fait fonctionner avec
les gens qui ont envie de travailler
avec vous et on reçoit la juste
rétribution l'investissement financier
et humain qu'on a mis dans la boîte. On
n'est pas là pour euh dire je fais la
quête aujourd'hui à la cathédrale. Ah
maintenant je vais chez monsieur le
maire plutôt. Ça ça existe pas. Ça
n'existe pas. Voilà. Et c'est et ça
c'est révoltant. C'est révoltant de ne
pas voir aujourd'hui les gens
s'apercevoir de la catastrophe qui
arrive. Et c'est révoltant de voir comme
réponse le chèque et l'aide. Et et moi
je je je pense que l'ensemble de mes des
gens que je connais, que j'apprécie,
avec qui je travaille depuis maintenant
pas mal d'années, tous ces gens-là, ils
n'ont pas besoin d'aide, ils ont besoin
de bienveillance, ils ont pas envie que
l'État leur envoie le fisque, leur
envoie le gendarme de l'environnement,
leur envoie le gendarme de de l'inspir,
le gendarme de c ou de ça. Ils ont
besoin de bienveillance. OK. Mais ils
n'ont pas besoin d'aide. Si ils ne
recherchent pas des aides. Ils sont pas
là pour faire des dossiers, pour avoir
des aides, pour que quelqu'un qui pense
euh au en haut lui dise "Ah oui, vous
avez bien fait là, alors vous recevez ça
euh comme à toutou avec le susucre." On
est les les gens les les gens ne
comprennent pas et mes homologues qui
sont plus jeunes que moi mais que mais
mais dont j'adore la manière de
travailler, ne comprennent pas pourquoi
on parle d'aide sans arrêt et de
subvention.
Il il travaillent suffisamment pour
pouvoir
faire en sorte que de subvenir tout seul
à leur besoin si jamais les embête pas.
Alors, on va faire une pause et on va
faire on va remonter la bobine et je
vais utiliser votre expérience de chef
d'entreprise de président de ELF qui
était une boîte pointe de diamant pour
la France.
Comment ça se passe quand on est à cet
hauteurlà, président directeur général
en terme de prospective et quels sont
les contacts avec l'État en terme de
prospective et de synchronisation de
l'action publique ? C'est-à-dire,
imaginez-vous,
on regarde les les métaux que
l'industrie a besoin. Là, on vient de se
rendre compte pardon, le gouvernement
vient de se rendre compte
le gouvernement. Oui, c'est c'est parce
que si jamais vous me lisez parce que ça
fait quand même ça fait 15 bouquins que
j'écris, si vous me lisez, vous
apercevez que je me rends compte depuis
longtemps.
Je confesse je confesse je ne vous ai
jamais lu.
Donc revenons à nos moutons.
C'est dommage.
J'espère que ça va changer.
On va peut-être se retrouver sur
certains sujets de prospective.
Allons-y.
Quand on voit que le gouvernement nous
fait une éème commission sur notre
dépendance au métaux, sur notre capacité
à acquérir les métaux pour notre
industrie, on est en 2022.
Est-ce que le gouvernement se réveille ?
Est-ce que le gouvernement prend en
considération la pression sociale en
terme de prospective, d'anticipation
et de projection ? Comment à votre
époque, avec tout le respect que je vous
dois,
on faisait pour dialoguer et faire un
plan à 30 ans ? Vous êtes les mains dans
le cambouille, vous êtes le PDG de ELF
qui a fait le plus de permis
d'exploration, d'exploitation
que tous ces prédécesseurs et tous ces
suiveurs.
Donc, comment on fait pour faire passer
au gouvernement ? Voilà, il faut qu'on
se projette sur ça, ça parce que si on
ne le fait pas, on cane. On canne sur
leschiquers international, on canne en
terme de concurrence et c'est notre
système français qui infé canner.
Est-ce que vous avez déjà eu des
contacts à l'époque avec les services de
renseignement, les services de
Pertention,
nous chef d'entreprise, on a une vision
de bon père de famille, on se projette à
long terme pour faire survivre notre
boîte, pour faire survivre nos employés
et on s'aperçoit que d'ici 10 15 20 ans,
la surcapacité de la France n'y est pas.
La surcapacité énergétique de la France
n'y est pas. Vous avez sans doute
remarqué ça. Est-ce que vous avez eu un
dialogue direct sur ces questions de
pénurie, de surcapacité, de guerre
économique, de il faut y aller avec les
dents, il faut y aller ? Écoute, quand
quand on est président d'elf, on est au
centre de cet ensemble, hein, cachons
pas les choses. À l'époque, hein, elle
fait la société nationale qui a été
faite pour dit pour rendre indépendant,
souverain la France en pétrole. Bah,
c'est ça le sujet. Donc le le bâton qui
m'est confié par le président Miteran à
l'époque, c'est dire maintenant comment
on fait ? Je dis grossièrement
aujourd'hui si je regarde les
raffineries que j'ai et le pétrole dont
je dispose dans les les puits, ça ça ne
le fait pas. il faut que je j'aille en
trouver ailleurs. Bon, donc je vais
accélérer le euh la l'exploration
partout où je peux, hein. Donc ça c'est
ça nécessite euh de d'avoir des
priorités et ça nécessite de d'avoir une
diplomatie qui permette de le faire,
hein. Donc donc en particulier à
l'époque euh je dis la la Russie ne va
pas rester indéfiniment comme elle est
et par conséquent il faut que j'ai des
contacts avec la Russie de manière à
pouvoir être non seulement en Russie
puisque il y a des gisements sibériens
dans dans le dans le nord mais qui sont
très difficiles à à exploiter mais dans
le sud c'est-à-dire
l'Uzbékistan
où où il y a du gaz, le Kazakhstan où il
y a du gaz et du pétrole et le
Turkménistan où il y a du gaz. Et donc
je je j'age dès dès le dès le départ en
arrivant l'idée qu'il va falloir
dialoguer avec avec tout le monde y
compris et c'est un un point important
d'y compris les régimes avec lequels on
n'est pas forcément en parfaite
intelligence démocratique hein. Donc
faut faut parler avec tout le monde et
et donc c'est ça le le le point le point
de départ. Alors par ailleurs, on dit on
va pas être uniquement sur sur le
pétrole puisque nous avions eu le choc
pétrolier en 1973, hein, et à l'occasion
du choc pétrolier, nous avons travaillé
sur l'indépendance de la France et sur
les différentes filières possibles pour
arriver à cette à cette indépendance.
C'est qui ? C'est-à-dire euh c'est euh
l'ensemble des acteurs économiques et de
l'administration de l'époque. Moi, je
suis euh une délégation générale à
l'achat scientifique et technique,
c'est-à-dire un organisme
public mais euh essentiellement des non
fonctionnaires. J'ai jamais été
fonctionnaire, hein. Je
ingénieur.
Je suis ingénieur. Je suis ingénieur et
je suis ingénieur énergéticien puisque
l'origine je suis hydraulicien et
d'hydraulique je suis passer à la
géologie parce que quand on fait des
barrages, on fait la géologie. Ensuite,
je suis parti euh dans le pétrole et
ainsi de suite. Bon, et puis à un moment
euh il s'avère que je travaille avec
deux personnages qui sont pas euh qui
sont pas très faciles d'accès. D'une
part, Pierre Guillaume qui a créé le CEA
et qui a
ensuite été patron d'elf et créateur
d'elf et puis d'autre part Girot qui a
été directeur des carburants et qui est
devenu ministre de l'industrie et un peu
le patron d'hydrocarbur français. Et et
donc on réfléchit à partir de 73 à ce
que va être euh ce que va être la France
demain et mais non pas en chambre avec
des fonctionnaires, il y a des
fonctionnaires bien sûr, mais
il y avait Bernardbert,
il y avait Bernardbert. Bernard Rombert
était chez Pompidou et était celui avec
lequel j'étais moi personnellement en
contact, c'est avec lui que j'ai pu
rencontrer le président Propidou. Et
donc à l'époque on est on est tous sur
la même longueur d'onde. C'est-à-dire
que il faut que les acteurs économiques,
les vrais soient là autour de nous.
C'estàdire que le plan tel qu'imaginez
aujourd'hui avec un commissaire au plan
qui vient de la planète Mars et qui dit
voilà ce qu'il faut faire. Tout ça c'est
absurde. C'est c'est pas ça le sujet. Le
plan c'est pas ça, c'est les acteurs
économiques qui se réunissent et qui se
concertent pour dire est-ce que on a
quelque chose à faire ensemble ? Est-ce
qu'on va quelque part ? C'est ça le
sujet. Et et le et disons que le le
fonctionnaire ou le chargé de mission
que j'étais puisque moi j'ai j'étais
chargé de mission, je suis là pour faire
prendre la sauce. Mais mais la sauce
c'est les acteurs économiques qui qui
sont en train de la faire. Et donc là on
est tombé sur les problèmes d'énergie
renouvelable. On est tombé sur le
problème nucléaire avec les euh les
neutrons rapides dont on parlera
peut-être tout à l'heure. Euh ensuite,
on est donc dans le nucléaire, on est
tombé sur l'avenir du du gaz et du
pétrole avec éventuellement pico gazol,
qu'est-ce qu'on arrive derrière ? On
sait en 73 quand on peut arriver et puis
on part sur tout ce qui peut être une
transformation de quelque chose,
c'est-à-dire la géothermie, la
méthanisation et cetera. Et à à cette
occasion, on crée en particulier le
commissariat à l'énergie solaire de
manière à essayer de voir comment
éventuellement avoir cette énergie
solaire qui est magnifique, qu' dont on
s'aperçoit qu'on la connaît très peu,
très mal puisque n'importe quelle plante
fait mieux que nous. He il faut bien
voir, n'importe quelle herbe a mieux
compris comment utiliser la la photèse
que nous. On a toujours pas compris. on
arrive pas à faire aussi bien et donc on
sait qu' qu'on peut qu'on peut faire
quelque chose de mieux et donc on fait
commissariat solaire et à une période où
on sait pas comment le baril va évoluer
et pendant le même temps euh
on on fait les euh les implantations en
mer de Norvège et en mer d'Angleterre
pour arriver à prendre le gaz et le
pétrole et et on et on prend des risques
insensés. C'estàd que le risque de la de
de l'implantation des des plateformes en
pleine mer de Norvège avec un un climat
épouvantable terra. On a on a pris on a
pris des risques on a pris des risques
avec
l'argent des Français pour arriver à ce
que en mer du Nord il y ait des
gisements de gaz qui nous servent compte
tenu de la connaissance que nous avions
de la capacité du gaz à résoudre
beaucoup de nos problèmes. Donc donc
c'est un ensemble de gens et dont on
distingue plus quels sont les gens qui
savent des gens qui savent pas. Euh le
problème c'est que tout le monde sait
quelque chose et qu'il faut les mettre
ensemble et que c'est cet ensemble qui
permet de dire voilà la ligne politique
que monsieur le président Pompidou ou
monsieur le président le Sardestin, il
serait bon que vous suiviez si jamais
vous voulez que la France devienne et au
reste un grand pays devienne un grand
pays au reste un grand pays. C'est ça
qu'on a fait. Bon et et ça c'est le bien
commun. C'est euh alors après chacun
trouve euh son sa capacité de tirer
meilleure partie de de l'effort qui a
été fait. Mais c'est c'est des filières
qu'on qu'on met qu'on met en place. on
on met pas en place des petits des des
bricolos dans son coin. Bon et lorsque
par exemple
je prends le dossier électrochimie
puisque c'est moi qui ai pris le dossier
électrochimie à l'époque bien on met
l'ensemble de d'électrochimies de de
France en route avec les les différents
laboratoires. On a 10 ou 15 laboratoires
en France on les met en cheville pour
qu'ils travaillent ensemble et on et et
on se projette avec est-ce qu'on va
faire des pieds des combustibles ?
Est-ce qu'on va faire de nouveaux de
nouvelles anodes et nouvelles cathodes ?
Quel est l'élect est-ce qu'on peut avoir
de l'électrolyte solide de façon à à
imaginer que on puisse transbaut
un peu mieux qu'avec l'électrol liquide
et c on fait un travail considérable.
Bon, mais on se projette dans le futur
et ceci est fait avec bien sûr en en
liaison, comme vous pouvez imaginer avec
les ce que vous appelez les services.
C'est-à-dire que euh si jamais euh on se
fait espionner, on veut savoir si euh on
se fait espionner et si jamais il y a
des gens qui qui espionnent, on a envie
de savoir où et comment et savoir un peu
ce qui se passe à travers le monde. Donc
tout ça, tout ça se fait. Donc il y a
les notes qui arrivent régulièrement.
C'est c'est notes blanche queon appelle
qui arrive régulièrement sur mon bureau
et que je lis ou je lis pas. Enfin, il y
a quelqu'un qui le lit de toute façon
hein. Voilà.
Donc maintenant, votre regard sur ce qui
se passe maintenant. Est-ce qu'on voit
des pilotes de pédalo qui naviguent à
vue ? Est-ce qu'on voit des mesurettes ?
Est-ce qu'on voit des des pansements sur
des jambes de bois pour éviter un
embrasement social ? Est-ce qu'on voit
une vision de la France ? Est-ce qu'on
et est-ce qu'on peut encore se permettre
d'avoir une vision de la France ? Est-ce
qu'on n pas tellement pas mité
de l'intérieur ? Est-ce qu'on n'est pas
véré de l'intérieur pour pouvoir
reprendre une souveraineté, une
indépendance ? Moi, je je suis d'une
grande résilience et je suis plein
d'espoir toujours. C'estd que si jamais
j'ai pas d'espoir, je je m'en vais,
hein. Donc, je reste en France, je suis
resté en France comme vous avez vu au
cours du temps et je considère que nous
avons encore énormément d'atout si
jamais nous nous voulons nous voulons
les jouer. Simplement, je ne vois pas
les joueurs,
plus les joueurs. C'estàd que je je vois
des des amateurs qui frétillent, hein,
mais je ne vois pas je ne vois pas le
joueur. C'estàd que je suis étonné que
sur un le le dossier énergétique,
il y a pas eu de il y a pas eu la
réaction. J'attendais.
C'était quoi la réaction ?
Et ben, les réactions, c'est simple.
Vous avez euh des réacteurs qui euh
fonctionnaient hier et hier toujours le
1er janvier de chaque année, l'ensemble
des réacteurs nucléaires était en
fonctionnement. C'est la règle Mesper
Pompidou. Le 1er janvier, il y a l'hiver
qui arrive. Il est arrivé un peu mais
peu importe mais il va arriver
grossièrement il y a un mois entre début
janvier et fin février. Alors en général
c'est je dis 15 janvier 15 février un
mois un mois et un mois où il fait froid
où il y a il y a pas de soleil il y a
pas de vent il y a pas il y a de la
neige il y a des et donc ce mois-là il
faut que tous les réacteurs sont en
fonctionnement.
Bon là on me dit bah non il y a il y a
pas tous les réacteurs parce que ils
sont en maintenance. Ah bon ? Très bien.
Euh qui a décidé
grand carrénage
quoi.
Le grand carénage.
Oui ou non ? Oui ou non ? Oui non c'est
pas aussi clair. C'est ils sont en
maintenance. Oui mais les grands
carénages mais il y a le Mais de quoi on
parle là ? Est-ce que ils sont en
maintenance ? Ils sont pas en
maintenance. Est-ce que parce que une
maintenance c'est quoi pour un pour un
réacteur ? Ça ça c'est une stification
précise. Cication précise doctrine je
dirais Pompidou Mesmer le 1er janvier la
fin de maintenance. C'est simple, c'est
c'est relativement classique. C'est
c'est comme ça que j'ai vécu, comme ça
que j'ai été élevé. Le 1er janvier,
c'est fini le le dossier maintenance.
Bon, alors ensuite, il y a eu un un
dossier qui est celui de la la corrosion
aux contraintes. La corrosion alors
alors ça fait joli contrainte. Qu'est-ce
que c'est ? Bah, c'est le le la sur le
réseau secondaire. Sur le réseau
secondaire, il y a 3 mm qui ont l'air de
de d'avoir posé problème sur 5 cm. Bon,
alors on découvre l'année dernière. Ah
bon ? Il faut simplement demander aux
gens qui savent. On a pas découvert
simplement l'instrument de mesure
est nouveau et a détecté que c'était
bien 3 mm. Moi, j'avais en tête 3 mm
aussi mais
on avait pas bien mesuré parce que la
seconde mesure était pas encore au
point. Là, on a 10 mm et on dit puisque
on a ça sur le circuit secondaire du
réacteur machin,
il y en a 7 pareils. Ça doit être pareil
pour les autres. J'arrête tout.
Mesure de précaution normale.
Non mais normal, qu'est-ce qui est
normal ? Qu'est-ce qui est normal ? Si
jamais si jamais j'ai sep machines
pareilles qu'il y en a une qui flanche
et je dis voilà s'il doit y avoir un
problème, j'arrête toutes les machines.
Moi je suis en faillite tout le temps.
Moi je dépose le bilan de tous les
entreprises industrielles françaises.
Qu'est-ce c'est cette histoire ? De quoi
s'agit-il ? Il s'agit du fait de bon il
y a un problème très bien traitons le
problème. Et puisque vous avez la semure
qui a traité le problème et que ça vous
et que ça vous fait peur, moi ça me fait
pas peur que le circuit secondaire soit
et 3 mm sur 5 cm alors que le chè qu' a
depuis 7 ans puisque c'est en 2014 ça
fait 2014 que j'ai su donc ça fait 8 ans
maintenant. Bon ça fait pas peur. Donc
très bien. Bon on va qu'est-ce que vous
voulez ? Vous voulez qu'on change le le
bout de le bout qui là ? On change le
bout si vous voulez. Ça va prendre un
peu de temps mais bon mais on arrête on
arrête un réacteur on arrête pas se
réacteur mais de de d'où d' d'où ça
vient ça ? Alors il y a ça. Donc on a
arrêté ce réacteur, on dire c'est un
réacteur fonctionne pas. Mais il y avait
qu'à les faire fonctionner et il y a pas
de danger. Il y a pas de danger. Il y a
pas de danger. Il fonctionnait avant.
Pendant 10 ans, ils ont fonctionné comme
ça. Ils peuvent continuer à fonctionner.
Il y a pas de danger. Si circuit
primaire, non. Si on est près du
réacteur, non. Mais on est circuit
secondaire, on est loin des
irradiations. On est loin de tout, hein.
Alors ensuite, on a Flamville.
Il y a quand même un dans le circuit
secondaire, je parle sous votre
contrôle, mais il y a quand même un peu
de radiation,
non ? sur de votre coup là
là. Absolument
d'accord.
Il y a rien.
Il y a rien. Non mais quel est le
problème ?
Non non non. Si on commence à avoir des
radiations secondaires et cetera, alors
il y a plus personne qui peut vivre euh
autour de de la centrale. Non mais bon
OK. On a FL fait l'avocat du diable.
Flamville. Flamville. à fem enville.
Bon, il y a eu un problème de soudure.
Bon, moi j'ai toujours considéré que le
problème de soudure qui était fait avec
les h soudures n'était pas dans le
circuit primaire, n'était pas un circuit
secondaire, était un circuit autour et
de sécurité et que c'était pas
dramatique. On attend si c'est
dramatique. Très bien. Bon, on arrange
tout. Mes anciens collaborateurs ont
tout arrangé de mon point de vue. J'ai
regardé le dossier, je pense que la
centrale peut aller en fonctionnement.
On décide qu'elle peut pas aller en
fonctionnement. Qui décide ? Qui a
décidé qu'elle pouvait pas aller en
fonctionnement ? Non, on va attendre la
mi de 2023. Pourquoi ? Moi, j'en sais
rien. J'en sais rien. Et et je et quand
je pose la question à mes anciens
collaborateurs, alors peut-être ils ont
peur de moi, mais mais ils me répondent
pas. Il me dit "Bah oui, c'est comme
ça." Alors derrière, vous avez Fenim ?
On dit "On vous arrê
Pourquoi vous arrê ? parce que elle est
la plus vieille en quoi ? Ben moi je
alors je suis vieux alors je m'arrête.
C'est cette histoire ça rien à voir. La
vieillesse n'a rien à voir. Le problème
est savoir si c'est maintenu. Vous
entendez ce ministre qui vous dit
maintenant on a arrêté parce que c'était
pas maintenu.
Vous avez un appareil industriel qui est
pas maintenu qui fonctionne ça existe
pas.
À chaque fois qu'il a quand il y a panne
a panne et quand il y a quand il y a
danger on arrête. Donc donc quand vous
avez un avion, l'avion est vieux alors
je vais pas dedans. Ben non, s'il vole
c'est qu'il a l'autorisation de voler.
Si l'autorisation de voler, c'est que
l'ensemble des travaux de maintenance a
été effectué pour qu'il puisse voler.
Il y a quelque chose qui va pas dans le
raisonnement.
Quel sont Attendez, je vous coupe.
Quelque chose qui va pas dans le
raisonnement.
Oui.
Ça veut dire quoi ?
des incompétents,
c'est il y a des raisons, c'est il y a
des gens qui pilotent notre politique
industrielle et énergétique de
l'extérieur.
C'est moi je dirais c'est tout à la fois
mais je suis peut-être méchant hein.
C'est le c'est c'est le c'est le
bénéfice de l' c'est le bénéfice de
l'âge de pouvoir être un peu méchant.
Mais je dirais que bon là quand non ce
que je ne supporte pas voyez au au bout
de c'est le mensonge technique. C'est on
dit la centrale de Fisenheim s'est
arrêté parce que elle était vieille. Non
ce n'est pas vrai parce qu'elle Non les
mensonges techniques, c'est pas
possible.
Elle s elle a été arrêtée pour des
raisons politiques pour plaire aux
écologistes politiques. Ça va ? C'est
clair. Bon, la même façon lorsque
on a arrêté Super Phonix, je reviens en
tron rapide qui est la politique moyen
terme. Donc il est clair que les
centrales d'aujourd'hui sont vont qu'on
pourrait faire aujourd'hui sont
meilleures que celle d'hier et moins
bonnes que celles qui sont de demain. He
c'est clair.
et que on sait que pour résoudre le
problème des déchets et le problème de
la disponibilité de combustible
nucléaire, si on prend les déchets des
centrales actuelles et qu'on les met
dans les réacteurs à neutrons rapide,
nous avons un cycle parfait et nous
pouvons continuer pendant 3500 ans à
utiliser en France les déchets
nucléaires pour avoir de l'énergie.
Bien, on le sait parce que les
physiciens ont travaillé pendant des
années et travaillé en 73 lorsqu'on a
pris le dossier. C'est pour ça que je
reviens à 73 et au au sujet euh de euh
de de pétrolier puisque on savait bien
que qu'on avait un problème pétrolier,
qu'on allait et qu'on à un moment il
fallait forcer autre chose. Et donc si
jamais on a travaillé sur le neutron
rapide, c'est en vertu du fait que on
savait que là on réglait le problème des
déchets et qu'on réglait le problème de
la pérennité électrique en France pour
3500 ans. C'est pas mal. Et et que on
avait trouvé la solution, c'est-à-dire
que le réacteur Super Phonix
effectivement faisait ce qu'on lui
demandait, c'estàdire utilisait les
neutrons rapides pour le le pour
produire l'électricité. Bon alors il
avait c'est un prototype pas conséquent
il il produisait pas tout le temps. Il
arrêtait de temps en temps, il remontait
dans ter
les politiques disent alors vous voyez
il a des pannes. Il y a pas de panne.
C'est un c'est un réacteur prototype.
Alors c'est prototype c'est pas une
question de panne question
d'expérimentation. Bon c'est c'est il
s'agit pas ah non il y a des pannes
alors on l'arrête. Non, il est arrêté
parce que et c'est bien clair la gauche
pluriel a voulu intégrer pour que
monsieur Jospin puisse être premier
ministre a voulu intégrer les
écologistes politiques de l'époque et
madame Voinet a exigé que dès le départ
on arrête le réacteur de tron rapide dès
97 et c'est la première mesure que le
gouvernement Jospin a pris en 1997 la
première mesure c'est pas il y a pas il
y a patron Sim qui c'est qui pris bon et
ensuite
les physiciens mes amis ont continué à
dire c'est quand même dommage d'avoir
cédé tout ça parce que qu'est-ce qui
s'est passé il y a eu des expériences
sur Fix les gens qui étaient là ils
avaient plus de job ils sont partis
ailleurs donc ils sont partis en Russie
en Chine aux États-Unis
tous plus ou moins en disant voilà j'ai
voilà ce qu'on a vu et c'est bien avec
le sodium liquide on va bien réussir et
donc ils sont partis et beaucoup sont
restés, beaucoup sont revenus et ont dit
il faut commencer. et on a repris un
projet qui s'appelle Astrid comme ça qui
pas qui coûtait pas trop cher et dans la
mesure où on a fait beaucoup de progrès
dans le numérique, on a fait beaucoup de
progrès sur la capacité de faire un
jumeau numérique en particulier avec
l'entreprise d'assau système, on on
savait comment simuler sans aller faire
les prototypes aussi importants que
Super Phenix et pour voir quelles
étaient les contraintes auxquelles on
allait être soumis et et son programme
Astrid a continué tranquillement et à un
moment il fallait non pas faire
l'échelle de Super Phonix mais faire un
prototype suffisant pour arriver à ce
que on on sache si vraiment par rapport
à Super Phéniix on avait fait des
progrès ou pas. Pendant le même temps,
on voyait les Chinois, les Russes et les
Américains qui faisaient des progrès
avec les données qu'on avait fourni et
donc on disait bon maintenant on doit
être à peu près dans les dans les clous.
Et en 2019, nouvelle décision
2019, c'est hier on arrête à streond
l'ordre hein. Quand on quand on voit
aujourd'hui que à chaque fois qu'on
donne un chèque, c'est un milliard pour
un chèque de 100 balles pour chacun
c'est un milliard. machin, c'est 5
milliards, 10 milliards et cetera. Bon,
il s'agissait de d'un milliard, c'était
c'est tu vois mais je dirais que euh
connaissant euh mes mes physiciens, on
leur aurait dit on continue avec 500
millions, ils auraient continué hein. Et
on a arrêté le programme à Street de
nouvelles fois. Bon, or c'est c'était la
chance de la France d'avoir
15 20 ans en avance des physiciens
nucléaires. La physique nucléaire
française était avec les les prix Nobel
que vous connaissez
la meilleure du monde et on avait de
l'avance sur le sujet. Alors là, on a
plus d'avance, on a peu importe, on est
quand même les Français, on a des
physiciens parmi les meilleurs du bon
encore. Donc on est capable de reprendre
le projet, on est capable de dire "Allez
maintenant, on sait qu'on a un problème
à court terme, on va avoir le problème
le on va on va régler le problème à
moyen terme. le prochain réacteur après
les six réacteurs que l'on fait
éventuellement si jamais ça passe les
six réacteurs qu'on passe pour passer
effectivement les années qui viennent on
va
on va les faire mais peut-être les
suivants vont être trop rapides de
manière à utiliser les déchets dès
maintenant et bien ça on le fait on on
névoque même pas la question alors vous
voyez on névoque pas cette question là
on névoque pas la la question de du
moyen
On rêve
une annonce la fusion marche notamment
la fusion c'est c'est long terme. Le le
le le réel moyen terme celui qui va nous
sauver c'est le neutron rapide c'est le
la fermeture du cycle qui a très bien
expliqué Yve Bréchet au aux
parlementaires. Alors est-ce que ça a
été au-delà des parlementaires ? Vous
avez essayé mais enfin tous les cas
c'est magnifique comme histoire
quoi.
Live Brchet magnifique.
Mais magnifique. Oui mais mais pendant
des années il a pas voulu parler parce
que il est parti il est parti parce
qu'on ne voulait pas poursuivre le con
le le programme Astrid. Il a à peine dit
il a dit oui j'étais pas d'accord parce
qu'on lisait pas mes rapports parce que
on qu'est-ce que c'était ? C'était
essentiellement que les conseillers des
ministres disaient non il faut arrêter
le problème Astrid. Il faut regarder il
a dit j'aime bien m'en aller plutôt que
de voir ça. Et donc il est parti à cause
de ça. C'est c'est pas moi qui le dit,
c'est c'est la réalité hein. Et et et
donc on voit qu' on ne s'occupe pas du
court terme, on s'occupe pas du moyen
temp dans ce domaine nucléaire qui est
essentiel pour nous. Mais vous direz bon
mais on s'occupe du reste, on s'occupe
bien, on s'occupe bien. Non, on s'occupe
pas. Vous savez le le nombre de petits
barrages qui qui de petits barrages
hydrauliques qui qui sont en train de se
d'être démolis aujourd'hui aujourd'hui
là tous les jours tous les jours il y a
des petits barrages un petit bar non on
l'enlève parce que le saumon arrive pas
à remonter hein la biodiversité la
biodiversité on l'oublie quand on fait
des éoliennes chez moi au Capfréel en
foutant en l'air l'ensemble de la faune
et de la flore et et de la beauté de
d'un d'un paysage magnifique du Cap Frel
et du Cap Derque. Mais par contre quand
il y a un saumon qui peut pas sauter, on
enlève le barrage. Le barrage
hydraulique, c'est pas bien.
C'est un peu caricatural. On peut faire
des passages à saubon.
Bah oui, mais malheureusement, on
supprime le barage. On aujourd'hui, le
nombre de petites
de petites centrales au fil de l'eau qui
disparaissent continue à être on en fait
une par mois, une par semaine, on
continue comme si de rien n'était, comme
si on avait l'électricité pour tous sans
dire difficulté. Non, c'est c'est il y a
aucune mesure d'urgence qui est prise
sur les hydrauliques. Alors à côté de
ça, il y a d'autres dossiers
hydrauliques qui sont même pas traité.
C'est qu' on les on les met sous le
boisson. L'hydraulique c'est compliqué,
c'est pasci, c'est pas ça, puis c'est
pas beau, puis c'est puis c'est mal vu
les écolos. Très bien.
Puis c'est quand même dangereux hein, un
barrage qui saute.
Oui.
Non.
Oui. Ben c'est très dangereux. C'est ce
qu'il y a de plus dangereux. C'est ce
qu'il y a de plus dangereux. Mais là en
l'occurrence ce qu'on supprime c'est les
c'est les petites les petites centrales
au fil de l'eau qui alors là elles ont
aucun danger elles ont jamais fait un
mort celle-là hein c'est clair. Bon
alors c'est ça donc les les les la
géothermie bon ben ça ça existe. On
pourrait dire j'ai fait un grand
programme géothermie rien. Bon euh sur
la méthanisation pour dire bah voilà il
y a il y a eu un effort de fait sur la
méthanisation des déchets et cetera.
Moi, j'ai rencontré des les les
métalliers,
les les gens les gens de qui font des
qui font de du méthan et cetera. Donc la
seule chose qui qui qui est importante
pour eux, c'est de pouvoir dire qu'il y
a 2 à 3 % de bio euh méthane dans les
tuyaux de gaz de de manière à ce que des
parasites euh vendent le l'ensemble de
du gaz en disant il y a du bio, il y a
du bio dedans, il y a du bio dedans.
C'est un peu plus cher, hein. Vous avez
c'est vous qui avez le bio le le bio
éthanol le c'est vous c'est vous qui
l'avez c'est vous qui l'avez hein c'est
c'est vous qui l'avez. Alors il y en a
un peu et et il y en a 45 qui l'ont et
qui ont leur certificat comme quoi ils
l'obtiennent. Donc tout ça tout ça c'est
c'est de l'habillage mais il y a pas de
politique. Donc on ne fait pas de
politique énergétique en France. Mais
surtout ce qu'il y a eu euh au départ,
c'est que on a une politique en disant
"Mais on aura moins besoin d'électricité
parce que euh parce que on va faire des
économies, on va on va on va on va faire
des économies et ça donc c'est pas la
peine de faire des de faire des vous
voulez faire des des centrales mais à
quoi ça sert ? on a on va pas avoir
besoin de temps d'électricité. C'est pas
vrai. Bon et et donc c'est la politique
2012, on va décroitre tranquillement et
en 2012, on dit on va décroître par
conséquent pourquoi faire des
d'électricité. Voilà, vous voyez donc
c'est c'est un tissu de mensonge de
mensonge technique, de mensonge réel,
d'incompétence, d'ignorance.
C'est votre interprétation
quoi ?
C'est votre interprétation.
C'est c'est moi je vous me demandez mon
avis. Ah moi je donne mon avis. Euh je
veux pas si c'est euh vous pouvez avoir
la la vidéo si jamais monsieur X ou
monsieur Y sont là autour de moi, ils
vont dire "Mais non, pas du tout, j'ai
fait euh j'ai fait ce qu'il fallait,
j'ai Mais moi je suis capou industriel.
Qu'est-ce qu'on regarde ? L'efficacité
c'est est-ce que la politique que j'ai
suivi a un succès ou pas ? C'est et
c'est facile hein. C'est je fais une
politique 5 ans après j'ai fait un
investissement 5 ans après est-ce que
j'ai mon résultat ou pas ? Si j'ai si
j'ai mon résultat, bah je dis j'ai
réussi et si j'ai pas de résultat j'ai
raté. Par conséquent, je fais un retour
d'expérience en disant puisque j'ai pas
réussi, pourquoi j'ai pas réussi ?
Qu'est-ce que je dois faire maintenant
pour corriger ? Là il y a rien, il y a
pas un mot. C'estàd que c'estàdire que
on a fermé Fenheim, on a perdu 1,8 GW.
Très bien. On ouvre Saintavolé il y a
quelques temps. On on regagne 1,8 MW G.
Saint charbon, c'est ça
charbon.
On a fermé le Havre. Personne parle du
Havre 1,8 GW encore hein. Bon, on en
parle pas.
C'est passé par on on parle de rien.
C'estàd que et on dit bien vous savez
vous avez à être sobre vous, il faut
vous attendie vous attendiez quand même
parce que faut pas prendre trop de
douche ça c'est pas bien. Pu si elles
sont trop chaudes, c'est vraiment pas
bien. Puis vous [__] de la gueule du
gouvernement. Est-ce que vous avez coupé
est-ce que vous avez coupé votre wifi en
partant de la maison ? ça que j'entends.
C'est ça que j'entends et j'entends
qu'il faut que je j'achète une voiture
électrique puisque c'est comme ça que je
vais me sauver alors que j'ai plus
d'électricité que et que et que si
jamais je j'utilise le vélo électrique
et et la marche à pied, c'est beaucoup
mieux. Je peux pas avoir une publicité
de bagnole sans avoir le fait qu'on me
dise immédiatement s'il faudrait mieux
quand même que vous preniez le vélo ou
ou le ou la marche à pied.
Qu'est-ce c'est ? C'est de la politique
ça. Est-ce que c'est de la politique ?
Je vous je suis désolé. C'est moi qui
doit répondre aux questions. C'est on a
changé de rôle. Rembobinons le film 72
premier choc pétrolier. Vous nous avez
dit on savait qu'on allait avoir un
problème
Oui.
de ressources.
Vous m'avez parlé du pic oil, du pic
énergétique. Oui.
Quel était l'état de vos connaissances
déjà à l'époque ? Quelles étaient vos
projections de de de soutenabilité du
modèle ? Quelles étaient vos projections
de soutenabilité du modèle ? avec des
puits qui avaient été mal forés, donc
qui n'allait pas pouvoir donner comme on
voulait à un prix qu'on voulait. Quel
combien d'années
on a on avait on avait le
Douvenez vos informations.
Oui. Oui. Alors donc on avait un d'abord
euh sur l'ensemble de la planète, je
pense que la France avait le meilleur
bureau de recherche géolique et minière
avec le BRGM. Donc on
et avec le commandant Coustau.
Voilà.
Si vous voulez enfin disons qu'en tous
les cas avec le PRGM nous savions
beaucoup de choses et c'était nous qui
étions un peu partout. Donc nous avons
nous avions un banque de données. Alors
on éétait pas informatisé mais on avait
des géologues, on avait donc on avait
des des armoires dans la compagnie de
géophysique
des armoires entières. OK. Bon alors
Munissa euh nous considérions à l'époque
que on avait pour 400 années de charbon
à peu près hein et qu'on avait encore
pour 73 hein pour 150 années de pétrole
et 200 années à peu près de gaz.
Alors à quel tarif tel quel tel taux de
croissance et ainsi de suite.
Alors alors donc le problème c'était le
tarif. Alors donc en charbon, le nombre
de mines de charbon qui à fleur est
extrêmement importante. Donc on avait
trouvé c'était les pétroliers qui
avaient trouvé en Chine les c'est
monsieur Hamur d'cident pétroléum qui
avait trouvé des kilomètres de de
charbon qui affleurit. On avait trouvé
la même chose en Inde. Donc on donc le
sur le charbon, on était sûr de nous.
OK. sur sur le pétrole. Euh nous étions
en train de de partir de d'une période
avec le colonel Drake en Pennsylvanie du
150 où on prend 5 % des gisements et on
était sur une dérive qui nous conduisait
à dire qu'on on pouvait avec l'ensemble
du travail des fait la réinjection de
gaz dans les puits et l'ensemble des
techniques bactériennes, on arrivait à
euh une utilisation une récupération de
l'ordre de 50 %. Bon et euh et nous
avions l'idée de zone où on pouvait
trouver euh du pétrole nettement plus
importante que celle qui était dans les
caisses.
Euh les recherches que nous avions
faites en Norvège en prévision du choc
pétrolier du Moyen-Orient hein. Si
jamais on était parti en Norvège et en
Angleterre, c'est qu'on avait peur de ce
qui se passait au Moyen-Orient
parce qu'il pipotaient leur chiffre.
parce qu'ils pipotaient leurs chiffres.
Non non non, on avait peur on avait peur
de ce qui allait se passer. C'estàdire
que c'est des zones instables et et
disons que la les grands pétroliers
français, c'est-à-dire Guillauma et
Girot, c'était les deux papes du pétrole
de l'époque, avait dit il faut
absolument aller aller en mer du Nord,
voir ce qui se passe en M du Nord. Donc
le le le travail de Maire du Nord était
un travail de précaution. Alors, la
bonne précaution pour moi, la bonne
précaution par rapport au délir éventuel
du Moyen-Orient qui était sous de minion
quand même américano anglais et on ne
savait pas trop ce qui allait se passer
compte tenu des rivalités à l'intérieur
des des deux ensembles et à l'intérieur
des compagnies. Bon, donc c'est notre
inquiétude conduisait à ça et conduisait
dans le même temps à aller en Afrique
voir ce qui se passait et d'où ce qui a
été réalisé au Sahara à l'époque par les
pétroliers français. Et c'est ça le
c'était ça l'idée. Alors euh l'idée
qu'on avait à l'époque, c'était que le
picoil qui avait été mis euh
relativement tôt euh était un un picoil
faux et que ça allait durer plus
longtemps. Et donc nous n'étions pas
inquiets là-dessus. Euh et l'inquiétude
a commencé après que j'ai été président
lorsque les gens du GC ont dit il faut
éradiquer le pétrole hein. Donc c'est
c'est c'est là, c'est au moment où Mais
nous n'éton pas inquiet sur le la
capacité du pétrole à rester à un niveau
relativement bas euh en prix pendant une
période relativement longue ?
Et vous étiez planté ?
Non, c'est pas planté.
Les gisements de mer du Nord.
Non non non, c'est pas planté. On a
beaucoup on a beaucoup pris le pétrole
de mer du Nord.
On a beaucoup on a beaucoup sué du Nord
pour maintenir les prix bas et pour pour
éviter que le Moyen-Orient ne monte trop
les prix. C'est c'était ça. On avait on
avait cette capacité de de jeu qu'on a
qu'on a pu tellement maintenant enfin
qu'on a médiocrement maintenant. Mais
disons que on on est on avait les pays
de l'OPEP et par conséquent il fallait
essayer d'éviter que les pays de l'OPEP
nous refassent le coup de 73 et donc il
et donc à chaque fois qu'il ne disait
nous on est on est on n'est pas
autosuffisant mais on est on est
quasiment autosuffisant. On aurait été
autosuffisant si en 1962 on avait gardé
le Sahara, hein, c'est clair. Mais on
était pas autosuffisant en tant que tel
dans l'état où nous étions. Donc
Sarah algérien.
Algérien. Oui. Alors et et on voyait
bien que les régimes
que alors chacun avait le sentiment
qu'il maîtrisait son régime. Les
Italiens avaient le sentiment qu' qui
maîtrisait la Libye puis ensuite ça a
été occidental pétrolum et les
Américains qui ont dit on maîtrise
Kaddafi. Donc chacun a le sentiment qu'à
un moment il maîtrise son dictateur qui
est sur les légisements de pétrole. Mais
aujourd'hui en particulier le
les Américains qui avaient beaucoup misé
sur Mohamed bin Salman disent "Mais
maintenant est-ce que tu peux augmenter
ton tes ta production ?" Et l'autre dit
"Non, moi je m'entends avec très bien
avec Poutine. Non, non, on est bien
comme ça." Vous voyez, donc c'est c'est
c'est pas facile. Bon et et donc le fait
de diversifier euh de diversifier est
important de la même façon que on
diversifie avec les avec tout ce qui est
en Amérique latine, le Venezuela et et
et qu'on sort. Donc je pense, je je
reviens à à me repose. Donc en en
pétrole, ce que nous avions observé,
c'est important parce que dans votre
question, c'est que euh la courbe
d'expérience nous conduit à diminuer le
coût d'extraction de manière assez
rapide. C'est-à-dire que lorsque nous
commençons en eau profonde euh à au en
mer du Nord, on dit "On va sortir le
pétrole au minimum à 12 dollars le
baril."
Bon et euh lorsque je vais au Nigéria et
que je vais en eau profonde encore plus
profonde que que les les gisements
antérieurs, là je suis à 16 dollars le
baril et l'ensemble de la communauté
pétrolière me dit "Tu es fou parce que
tu tu c'est beaucoup trop cher et tu
n'arriveras pas à descendre."
Et et en fin de compte, ce n'est pas
vrai. C'est-à-dire que au bout d'un
certain temps, avec tous les progrès
techniques que l'on fait, on arrive à
baiser de 16 à 4 ou 16 à 5 ou 16 à 6.
Donc donc les les progrès euh sur le
prix euh du pétrole comme sur le prix du
gaz sont considérables à tout moment et
c'est ce qui rend les raisonnements euh
des autres filières, j'y reviendrai tout
à l'heure, euh contestable parce que euh
on fait des progrès et on on maîtrise
beaucoup plus des progrès dans
l'extraction pétrolière, l'extraction
gazière parce que pendant 100 millions
d'années, il y a des gens qu'on connaît
pas qui ont travaillé dans le sous-sol
et qui ont fait des trucs gratuits,
hein. Et et et donc on bénéficie de de
tout ce qui a été fait en mastération de
de produits organiques pendant des des
centaines de millions d'années. Et alors
donc on avait tout ça en caisse si vous
voulez et
on s'est orienté néanmoins vers les
techniques nouvelles qui permettaient de
nous en sortir. S'il a s'il y a un sujet
que nous n'avons pas traité à la période
de 73 parce que nous considérions qu'il
était marginal, c'est celui qui fait
écho aujourd'hui en grand
en en grand
en grande pompe qui est l'éolien.
Pourquoi ?
Alors il faut expliquer pourquoi
avant de passer sur l'éolien
là on en est où ? J'entends des gens me
dire les les gisements au mer du Nord
ont passé leur pics.
Oui,
j'entends j'entends
oui et non. C'est-à-dire que la Norvège
a des gisements euh qui ont été
découverts et la Norvège a une politique
de mettre en fonctionnement les
gisements quand il leur paraît utile
compte tenu du prix du baril ou du prix
du gaz. Donc la Norvège a encore
beaucoup de gisements découverts qui ont
qui sont en état de fonctionnement et
qui ne mettent pas en fonctionnement
parce que c'est pas le moment hein. La
nouvelle est positive très
conservatrice. C'est un petit pays qui
vit essentiellement sur le pétrole et le
gaz en utilisant autre chose et en
mettant son argent dans le le green
washing hein. Donc c'est c'est sympa
comme régime mais c'est mais c'est très
efficace parce que plus vert que plus
vert que les Norvégiens tu meurs et
simplement ils ne vivent depuis des
années que parce que Elfakiten la
compagnie dont j'étais président a voulu
trouver du gaz et du pétrole en Norvège.
C'est là-dessus qu'il vivent. C'est
c'est voilà donc c'est plus compliqué
que ça voyez. Donc c'est
donc là il nous reste quoi en terme de
alors il alors en terme en terme de
gisement on trouve des gisements partout
aujourd'hui. Alors il
combien de millions de barils capable de
donner combien de millions de barils par
jour ? Alors on est on peut très bien
continuer encore pendant un grand nombre
d'années à faire à faire à faire les de
baril qu'on faisait avant. C'est pas
c'est pas il y a rien de il y a il y a
pas de drame aujourd'hui. Le drame c'est
que on a arrêté un certain nombre
d'exploration
un certain nombre d'investissements un
certain nombre de et que on embête les
gens qui veulent investir. Donc donc par
exemple quand quand on trouve un
anguanda,
ça nique un peu le climat quand même non
? Ça nique un peu le climat.
Oui mais il faut savoir ce qu'on veut.
On va on va on reviendra là-dessus quand
vous voulez, hein. Mais enfin, il faut
pas faut pas tout mélanger. Donc moi, je
dis euh je suis sur le pétrole, je suis
sur l'énergie, j'ai euh une j'ai un
dispositif avec euh du pétrole, du gaz,
du nucléaire, euh
de l'hydraulique euh et des énergies
euh euh dites renouvelables et qu'ils
sont pas forcément. Bon, donc voilà le
le le panel que j'ai et et j'ai par
ailleurs des matériaux
dont
qui que qu'on peut les trouver partout
mais
il y a des gisements magnifiques dans
certains pays seulement et ces gisements
sont euh mettons au au puisque c'est la
c'est à la tonne de matériaux pris qu'
qu'on Faut regarder. Donc là aujourd'hui
sur l'or, je vais chercher le gram par
tonne, hein. Bon alors sur les autres
matériaux, mais il faut que je regarde à
combien de grammes par tonne je suis et
combien ça va me coûter pour savoir si
c'est intéressant de continuer à
travailler dessus. Et alors si les prix
augmentent effectivement je j'ai des
réserves plus importantes. Donc j'avais
émis la le théorème à l'époque en 1973.
euh on me disait quelles sont les
réserves ? Et et j'avais répondu
théorème numéro 1, les réserves
augmentent avec le prix. Et puis 2è
théorème qui est clair, hein, ce qui est
rare et cher, hein. Donc voilà. Alors
après maintenant, vous regardez, vous
mettez à la sauce. Bon, alors vous
pouvez très bien à un moment dire oui,
mais j'ai je reviens très légèrement sur
le sujet. Prenez votre temps.
J'ai
un produit qui a des économies externes
énormes à cause euh du de ces émissions
qui est le pétrole et le gaz. Sur ce
pétrole, je vais faire une taxe carbone
qui va permettre de rééquilibrer par
rapport à d'autres à d'autres énergies.
Alors, ça c'est c'est euh c'est l'idée
qu'il existe une sorte de gouvernement
universel qui décide de la manière dont
les choses se font. Bon alors cette
hypothèse des existences d'un
gouvernement universel qui va réguler he
qui est l'espoir de tous les
technocrates. Non ce heurte à la réalité
c'est-à-dire que lorsque vous êtes en
Silésie en Pologne et que vous êtes sur
un gisement
de de charbon qui à fleur qu'est-ce que
vous faites ? Vous l'utilisez ou vous
l'utilisez pas ?
Est-ce que vous plantez des carottes ou
vous vousou vous vous utilisez le
charbon ? Si vous plez des carottes,
vous risquez de pas avoir de carottes.
Par contre, si jamais vous utilisez le
charbon, vous risquez avoir de
l'énergie. Donc, vous utilisez
l'énergie. Donc, tant qu'on est dans des
endroits où le l'énergie est pour
l'énergie fossile est pour rien ou
presque rien, comment voulez-vous éviter
que les populations qui ont faim
utilisent ça en disant "Ah, en Poland,
il y a du soleil utiliser l'énergie
polaire en utilisant disant il y a du
vent à utiliser le vent." Non, c'est
qu'ils vont utiliser ils vont utiliser
le charbon. il pouvit utiliser moins et
donc le sujet pour moi n'était pas à
l'époque où le l'ensemble des des euh
des données climatiques ont été ont été
fournies où on était à 88
% d'énergie fossiles utilisées dans le
monde. n'était pas de dire on va
éradiquer une fossile,
c'était de dire on va regarder comment
améliorer les rendements, améliorer des
économies pour savoir au moment où il y
a la où ça verse du côté nucléaire, où
ça verse du mais on va regarder ça,
c'est ça le sujet. Et si jamais on prend
un sujet comme ça, vous vous souvenez
qu'en 73 vous vous souvenez pas. Moi je
m'en souviens. Donc avec avec André
Girot, avec André Girot, on a on a on a
dit on va voir si on peut faire la
voiture 1 L au 100.
Est-ce que Non mais ça c'est une
connerie la voiture 1, 100.
Et pourquoi ?
Parce que plus vous faites une voiture
qui consomme moins, plus tout le monde
achète. Donc on se retrouve tous avec
des bagnoles à 1, L au 100.
Regardez avant les voitures consomment
30 L au son. Ouis.
D'accord. Il y avait très peu de
personnes qui avaient des bagnoles.
C'est c'est ça rien à voir.
Regardez en Inde avec des petites boîes
à 1 L au 100 ou
tout le monde va avoir. Tout le monde va
avoir.
Non, justement ça a pas marché ça ça là
vous trompez là excusez-moi.
Ceux qui ont ceux qui ont voulu faire la
petite voiture pas chère en Inde se sont
plantés
et donc parce que les gens qui ont une
voiture ont envie d'avoir une vraie
voiture.
C'est une vraie voiture.
Non non non. Et donc ils ont fait une
voiture qui a des accélérations, qui a
des donc c'est c'est c'est parce que la
société a envie d' chose. C'est on est
dans le temp sur la
Est-ce que je peux est-ce que je peux
vous couper ? Bien sûr.
Les pétroliers toutes tous les droits.
C'est vrai tous les droits. C'est vous
le patron.
Est-ce qu'à l'époque les pétroliers
étaient au courant que le pétrole ça
foutait le climat en l'air ?
Non.
C'est vrai ou c'est pas vrai ça ?
Non non non c'est idiot. J'ai j'ai
répondu j'ai répondu. J'ai fait un
complément d'enquête sur le sujet euh
sur le sujet. Et le jeune homme qui
était là me disait "Mais non, regardez,
il y a les rapports". Non, non, non, ce
n'est pas vrai, hein. Donc, on a
commencé on a commencé à parler euh à
parler de ce sujet euh avec des avec des
pincettes euh dans euh à la fin de
mon de mon mandat de de ELF, euh,
c'est-à-dire en 1992.
Donc c'est 91 92 où on dit il y a il y a
à l'époque où je suis président,
ce dont on parle c'est du gaspillage et
du torchage.
C'est moi et c'est moi qui porte à
l'époque le drapeau contre le torchage
de gaz en disant "C'est une honte de
torcher un si bon produit que le gaz.
C'est moi qui a fait ça, hein. C'est moi
qui vais porter la parole partout en me
faisant euh insulter partout où je vais
en disant "Non, c'est pas possible." et
et qui fait le les programmes que j'ai
initié en Afrique de de dopage
d'égisement de pétrole en réinjectant le
gaz et en et et en diminuant le torchage
hein. Mais à l'époque, on torche le gaz
dans tous les pays du monde hein dans
donc on a on a même pas l'idée de
conservation et de non gaspillage hein.
C'est ça la réalité. Alors, on peut
réécrire l'histoire comme on veut, mais
c'est disons que alors alors ils m'ont
trouvé un rapport disant que il y a Oui,
d'accord. C'est oui, il y a peut-être
des rapports. Disons que à l'époque ce
n'est pas l'objet. L'objet c'est de
savoir si nous allons pouvoir euh
utiliser le pétrole et le gaz avec un
meilleur rendement
pour arriver à le conserver depuis
longtemps. C'estàd que que nous avons le
sentiment de Gasp et et c'est
effectivement l'inverse qui va être fait
par rapport à à la période dont je
parle, c'està dire où je suis président
d'elf c'estàdire qu'on va partir sur le
SUV et sur les grosses bagnoles qui font
qui qui vont déb de de camelotte alors
que à l'époque on est en train d'essayer
de raisonner autrement. C'estàd dire
est-ce qu'on pourrait euh ce produit est
un produit magnifique, le pétrole euh il
est utilisable dans la chimie, sur les
routes dans le bitume, il est dans les
avions, il bon est-ce que on peut
essayer de de de le préserver un peu
mieux ? on on l'utilise un peu à tort et
à travers et et donc alors les
constructeurs de voiture
sont pas pour et les cons de voiture le
consommateur c'est pas ça qu'il veut ils
font autre chose
on est dans dans et et là il y a pas de
régulateur mondial il y a pas il y a pas
de il y a il y a est-ce que c'est est-ce
que c'est un défou qu'il ait pas de
patron mondial je ne le pense pas je je
n'ai pas envie dans romance
science-fiction on voit le on voit le le
l'organisateur mondial qui est qui est
là C'est c'est du hor plus mais c'est
pas terrible. Bon donc je pense qu'il
faut donner à chaque à chaque pays à
chaque région la possibilité d'utiliser
au mieux ses ressources
et lorsque je vois les bobos parisiens
dire mais c'est facile ils ont du soleil
en Afrique alors ils ont qu' utiliser le
soleil faut mettre des pâtovtaiïques
partout. Je dis moi qui vécu 30 ans en
Afrique, je leur demande de venir à un
orage tropical, de mettre des photos des
des panneaux photovoltaïque et de voir
après un orage tropical ce qu'il en
reste. Ils pourront dire après qu'en
Afrique, il y a toujours du soleil.
En Bretagne, il y a toujours du soleil,
je peux vous le dire, mais en Afrique
non. Il y a souvent des orages
tropicaux. Très bonne coquille
Saint-Jacques à Herky d'ailleurs. Non,
il
y a des coquill Saint-Jacques et à
Herky. Bien sûr.
Le politique dans tout ça, comment vous
percevez les politiques ? Vous allez
vous avez côtoyé Tonton ?
Euh vous voyez Popidou Jisca euh Mitéran
bien sûr pendant 21 ans euh et euh
7 ans avant et après 14 ans hein, c'est
7 ans en avant et 7 ans de Giscar. Je je
et euh et ensuite je connais je connais
mais on peut pas dire que j'ai été avec
hein. Donc je connais ceux qui ceux qui
ont suivi sauf le dernier. Voilà. Et et
donc et donc je pense que c'est pour moi
c'est la descente aux enfers dans la
gestion. Alors, c'est peut-être à cause
de la politique de l'information qui est
différente, à cause euh de euh de de
d'internet, à cause c'est peut-être
parce que les les circonstances de la de
la vie politique ont changé parce que c
mais si vous voulez le les gens que j'ai
rencontré euh à à du avec Pompidou,
c'est des gens qui qui écoutaient, qui
réfléchissaient
et et qui euh et et qui disait
Alors, c'est j'ai c'est avec ces gens-là
que j'ai vécu avec des et et
je me trouve assez mal dans l'idée que
aujourd'hui
euh on prend des décisions qui
m'apparaissent particulièrement émotive.
J'ai l'impression il y a un problème
pof, on prend une décision, il y a on
répond tout de suite. Alors
c'est ça qui a changé pour moi et ça a
commencé ça a commencé assez rapidement.
Bon c'est Chirac de mon point de vue
réfléchissait quand même moins que les
les précédents. Mais mais mais après
c'est c'est de l'émotion. On on a une
information, hop, on dit voilà ce qu'on
fait.
Moi si jamais en tant que chef
d'entreprise je fais ça, je fais failli
de vite.
C'est que c'est plus compliqué que ça la
visia forcément.
Pensez est-ce que vous pensez que la
France va faire faillite ?
Elle est déjà en faillite. Le problème
c'est savoir comment elle se redresse
pour moi.
Pourquoi pourquoi elle est déjà en
faillite ?
Bah déjà en faillite parce qu'elle est
trop endettée et que elle a un commerce
un un déficit commercial trop important.
Donc on est en faillite de fait. on est
en faillite. Bon, c'est clair. Euh
maintenant, ça veut pas dire qu'on a pas
de ressources, mais disons qu'on est en
faillite. Bon et et donc il faut se
redresser comment on se redresse ? C'est
ça c'est ça le sujet pour moi. C'est ça
le sujet. Et donc et donc et donc le
sujet pour moi en conséquence, c'est de
faire de l'industrie et d'énergie parce
que si j'ai pas d'énergie, j'ai pas
d'industrie et pour faire de
l'industrie, il faut que je montre que
je suis compétitif. Un des rares
endroits où j'étais compétitif, c'était
c'était de l'énergie. Et et si j'ai pu
ça, c'est pourquoi je suis compétitif ?
Parce que je suis bien meilleur que les
autres. Parce que je suis plus
intelligent. Non, une grande armée.
Pourquoi ? Pourquoi pourquoi je serais
plus intelligent ? Alors, je serais plus
intelligent si et c'est c'est là le
point fondamental qu'il faut que les que
que tout le monde comprenne, c'est que à
un moment les gens ont cru que parce
qu'ils étaient intelligents, ils
pouvaient savoir-faire et faire. Et donc
ils ont dit allons faire n'importe où.
Or celui qui sait faire celui qui fait
ça c'est dans le mot c'est dans le mot
savoir-faire. Savoir faire on sait faire
si on fait. Bon et et là ils ont dit on
va on va envoyer ça en Chine, on envoyer
ça en Inde, on va envoyer ça au Vietnam,
on va envoyer et cetera et alors après
on aura des produits pas cher et comme
c'est nous les plus intelligents, on va
C'est pas c'est pas ça qui se passe.
C'est pas ça qui se passe. Quand on fait
pas, on sait pas faire et donc faut pas
compris le raisonnement Loïque.
Maintenant vous avez pas compris le
raisonnement. Maintenant on a le savoir
pas faire et on prend le pognon et puis
après on se retrouve le bec dans l'eau.
C'est ça si je résume correctement.
Ben, c'est-à-dire que je aujourd'hui
moi ce que j'aimerais c'est qu'on me
dise plutôt que de on va
réindustrialiser
comment sans énergie. Je voudrais je
voudrais qu'on me dise comment on va
éviter la faillite des 150000 à 300000
entreprises à la fin de l'année. Ça,
j'aimerais être petit de j'aimerais
qu'on me dise comment on va faire pour
mettre le prix d'électricité
au même niveau que nos voisins. Non pas
non pas non pas non pas moins cher. On
le on le fait moins cher. C'est que les
voisins vont le faire en ce qui concerne
l'électricité puisquon va prendre
l'électricité à 115
€ le mégawh. Il vont c'est ça qu'ils
vont faire. Bien. Nous on le fait à 50 €
le mWh.
Et moi industriel je l'achète je
l'achète à 600 € le MWh. On me dit on me
dit oui c'est pas de chance. Il y a pas
de chance. Et donc j'ai pas de chance.
J'ai pas de chance. On dit mais on va si
tu es gentil, si tu fais bien les
dossiers, si tu on va peut-être te
mettre un bouclier à 300. Alors ça varie
est-ce que 382 328, on sait pas dans
quel ordre c'est le 2 et le 8. Bon, ça
300 peu importe, c'est trois fois plus.
Moi je peux pas je peux pas être cif à
trois fois plus. Donc donc j'ai besoin
dans les aider les cours qu'on me dise
comment on va euh me mettre à 115
comme les autres. On me dit c'est pas
possible. Bah je dis pourquoi c'est pas
possible ? Parce qu'il faut qu'on aille
acheter l'électricité chez les autres.
C'est là que je reviens sur tout ce que
j'ai dit sur les centrales nucléaires et
les centrales à charbon à à fioule, les
barrages et cetera, hein. J'ai j'ai j'ai
j'ai dit voilà ce qu'on peut faire. Et
on peut le faire dans combien de temps ?
Mais dans un mois. Là, on est début
décembre, dans le 15 janvier,
on y est, on y est. Dans dans dans un
mois, on peut remettre tout ça en route
si on a envie. Si on a envie. Et si on
le fait pas, c'est qu'on a pas envie.
Bon si pourquoi vous avez pas envie ?
Est-ce que vous voulez tuer encore
150000 ou 300000 entreprises de nouveau
? C'est que on a déjà tué pas mal.
Est-ce qu'on veut absolument tuer ces
entreprises ?
Alors je vous coupe.
Vous avez raison de me couper parce que
je sais plus où je vais là.
Vous inquiétez pas,
vous avez compris.
EDF est en train de nous sauver là. Du
moins, le personnel de DF réactive nos
réacteurs. Là, on est à 42 et c'est en
monter en puissance.
Oui.
42/ 56. Heureusement qu'ils sont là.
D'ailleurs, j'en j'en profite encore
pour leur passer un petit coup de
polish. Pendant le Covid, ils ont été
extraordinaire.
Extraordinaire bien sûr
et on en a pas assez parlé. Nous, on
avait des informations de l'intérieur
des réacteurs et ils ont été
extraordinaires et ce sont les seuls qui
ne couraient pas comme des poulets sans
tête.
Est-ce que vous avez déjà discuté ?
Est-ce que vous avez déjà fait venir
dans ce fauteuil un directeur de
centrale nucléaire ? Vous voyez les mecs
que c'est ? C'est fantastique ces types
là. Ils ont sur le dos des trucs
extraordinaires. Don ils ont et et là on
leur a collé le pire qu' soit. C'eston
l'a collé. Non, vous avez pas d'argent,
vous pouvez pas faire la maintenance. Si
vous la faites, il faut le faire tout de
suite. Il faut ceci sans clés,
il faut démonter sans sans avoir de
dispositif d'urgence. C'est que moi
quand je suis je suis industriel, bon
j'ai une machine qui pète. Très bien.
Machine qui pète. Mais dit ça c'est
embêtant parce qu'on va pouvoir pouvoir
livrer hein. On est même ou très bien
parfait. Combien de temps ? Bah ça prend
du temps parce qu'il faut aller chercher
très bien parfait. Bon et je mets en
dispositif d'urgence c'est-à-dire que je
travaille jour et nuit 7 jours sur 7. Ah
oui c'est urgent.
Heureusement qu'il y a l'inspection du
travail quand même.
Et donc on va à l'inspection du travail
et on négocie du travail. On dit voilà
j'ai Est-ce que ça ça va tard ? Est-ce
qu'ils sont d'accord ? Oui ils sont
d'accord. Très bien l'inspire de travail
vient voir d'ord on a la permission de
faire et on travaille ça pour que les
machines soient en route le plus
rapidement possible pour satisfaire le
client le client est roi c'est bien
connu. Bon là c'est pas urgent hein. Les
mecs se sont mis en urgence eux-mêmes
mais personne leur a dit de se mettre en
urgence. C'est eux-mêmes qui ont
travaillé un peu plus qui ont c'est le
travail qui a été fait et les
sous-traitants les sous-traitants parce
que les sous-traitants ils travaillent
pas tout seul les gens externalisation
il travaillent pas tout seul il y a
quand même il y a quand même 200000 mecs
qui travaillent dans le nucléaire en
France qui ont continué à trava
conditions souvent difficiles
quo
dans des conditions souvent difficiles
absolument et qui et qui ont et qui se
sont maintenu les boîtes sont maintenues
grâce au travail en Chine grâce au
travail en Finlande et en Angleterre Et
en Angleterre, ils aiment pas les
Français qui travaillent. Par
conséquent, ils ont du mal à travailler
en en Angleterre. Bon, et ces mecs-là,
ils ont continué à travailler mais on
leur passait pas de contrat parce que
les contrats, il fallait faire des
appels d'offre. Les appels d'offre, mais
pourquoi c'est si pourquoi c'est si
cher, il y a pas d'argent ? et ainsi de
suite. Donc donc il il y a les les les
conditions dans lesquelles les les gens
de DF ont travaillé pendant sa dernière
période sont dag complètement dag et ils
ont réussi effectivement et ils
continuent à j'espère qu'ils vont
réussir à faire mais si jamais
j'espère qu'ils vont tenir le coup
surtout
mais si jamais mais si jamais on pouvait
aller au-delà de des travaux qu'ils font
et faire en sorte que cette contagion
des des de la corrosion sous contrainte
ne soit pas considéré comme éternel, ça
pourrait aller plus vite encore. C'est
qu'on pourrait remettre 5 si réacteurs
beaucoup plus vite en en circulation là
dans les dans les semaines qui viennent.
Il faut faire quand même un peu gaffe
avec les risques. J'ouvre une
parenthèse.
Le gaz naturel de chist
qu'on importe des États-Unis.
Oui, c'est on est un premier
importateur. Oui.
Donc à quel tarif est-ce que c'est
soutenable ? Attendez.
Bah plus cher plus cher que hein. Plus
cher que leur
Oui, même Macron. Macron Macron
c'est normal c'est normal.
Macron a gueulé un peu. Alors bon on
sait pas si ça avoir de grands effets et
revenons à nos moutons sur le gaz
dechiste. On voit les Allemands nos nos
notre couple notre moitié notre mi
européenne
être dans la mouise dans la panade avec
ce qui se passe avec la Russie en terme
énergétique.
Bien. Pourquoi ?
Pourquoi
il est encore bien vert le vieux quand
même he ? On me laisse terminer ma
phrase. Pourquoi ? Pourquoi ? parce que
ils ont dit que ils faisaient des
éoliennes et que les éoliennes
satisfaisaient à tous leurs problèmes et
et que ils avaient pas besoin d'autre
chose. C'està-dire qu'ils ont menti à
leur peuple et au peuple au peuple
européen en disant que c'était grâce aux
éoliennes qui faisaient l'électricité en
Allemagne. C'était pas c'était pas ça.
C'était à cause de l'éolien et du gaz.
Et donc leur politique gazière,
c'està-dire la politique de avec la
Russie, avec le gaz pas cher arrivant
directement sans passer par les
l'Ukraine ou la Biolorussie ou la
Pologne, c'est euh pour avoir la
capacité de pouvoir dire à tout le
monde, regardez, on est les meilleurs,
on a des éoliennes. Les éoliennes qui
fonctionnent 25 % au maximum du temps.
Il y a 75 % gaz ou charbon. C'est voilà.
Donc la politique gazière, c'est la
politique industrielle
de l'Allemagne qui est basée sur le gaz
en disant que c'est sur l'éolienne
qu'elle est basée.
Chune.
Mensonge.
Revenons à nos donc les Allemands,
quel âge vous avez ? Rappelez-moi
pas vieux.
Pas 52 ans. C'est ça.
C'est ça. Et des poussières. Allez-y.
Ouais. Quelques euh les Allemands là,
ils sont en train de courir pour faire
des terminaux pour détendre le gaz de
chiste.
Ils ont jamais voulu. Ils ont jamais
voulu. Il ils interdisaient les verrs
ont interdit de faire des terminaux.
Donc donc nous nous avons initié la
politique en France, la politique des du
gaz naturelqufié. C'est nous qui étions
présidents du groupe quand j'étais
président de Gaz de France, c'était moi
le président de du du consortium du gaz
naturel du kéfier mondial. Bon et nous
avions la technique des métaniers et et
c'est on a grossièrement la technique
des métaniers français recouvre la
moitié de tous les méthagniers mondiaux.
Bon et les Allemands voulaient pas les
Allemands voulaient pas voulent pas. Non
non non, on prend pas gagner. Non non
non non non. Ils ont combattu le fait
queon fasse des terminaux. Alors, on a
fait on a quatre terminaux hein, mais
d'un kerk d'onge et puis
une capacité de combien ?
C'est variable, enfin c'est c'est plus
compliqué.
Au taquet au taquet combien ? Au taquet
combien ?
C'est euh c'est c'est compliqué parce
que comme ils sont liés au stockage et
qu'on a fait les stockages, c'est
compliqué. Groèrement, si jamais je
compte l'ensemble de des terminaux
gaziers, plus de stockage, plus de
stockage, on a la consommation de gaz
français pour une année à peu près.
La consommation dans Non, non,
vous plantez là.
Non, non.
Sûr ?
Non. Non.
Donc les capacités de stockage de la
France en terme de gaz, c'est 25 % de
notre consommation.
Non, plus que ça. Ah, c'est
consommation. Ah, c'est bon. C'est bon.
C'est on a on peut fonctionner avec nos
stockages
souterrain et gain naturelqufié.
On peut fonctionner pendant pendant une
année sans trop de problème. Voilà
pour aujourd'hui.
Revenons revenons aux Allemands Pierre.
Après, on va revenir sur nous en terme
de parce que je suis pas bien sûr de ce
que vous racontez là quand même.
Et ben tant pis, tant pis. Vous mais
vous vérifierz
mais grossièrement je je ne vois pas
aujourd'hui avec le stockage que nous
avons et les terminaux gaziers je nous
vois pas en pénorie de gaz si jamais
nous conservons notre gaz le problème
c'est que nous l'ch
c'est que quoi on peut pas recharger
on peut recharger quoi
bah notre capacité de stockage en gaz
quand on va sortir de l'hiver si on se
tape un hiver rigoureux on va ressortir
avec un stockage à quoi 5 10 % on a
quand même on a quand même l'Algérie la
Norvège. l'Algérie, ils ont l'air de
dire bon
la Norvège elle a l'air de dire qu'on va
vendre aux autres
des arrangements avec le ciel. Non non
mais je dire si à Norvège vont tout à
l'Allemagne peut-être enf non
il y a toujours trial toago il y a
toujours
en gaz naturel liquéfié on a quand même
des poires pour la soif non je suis pas
vraiment sur la pénurie de gaz j'ai j'ai
pas d'angoisse par contre sur le prix du
gaz oui hein c'est différent he c'est
c'est ça le sujet le sujet c'est le prix
moi j'ai effectivement on dit on dit à
tout le monde attention attention
pénurie pénurie non si jamais on n pas
envie de pénurie de gaz on n pas de
pénurie de gaz si par contre il faut
payer oui alors on payera 10 fois plus
que que et le le problème c'est que on
va payer 10 fois plus que les américains
chez eux par conséquent aujourd'hui les
industriels qui veulent investir et qui
ont le choix entre investir en France ou
aux États-Unis ils partent aux
États-Unis et c'est pour ça que Safran
qui est dans dans le travail qu'il doit
à être très consommateur d'énergie dit
je comptais investir en France mais j'ai
pas de raison et comme je je travaille à
la fois pour les
l'Europe et les États-Unis et et que le
marché des États-Unis a l'air de de
d'aller plus rapidement, je vois pas
pourquoi j'investis en France. Donc
c'est c'est le prix qui est important.
C'est-àdire que on me on me ramène sans
arrêt sur le problème de la pénurie et
de des délestages, des coupures et
cetera. Bon, moi je suis un vieil
africain, moi j'ai vécu les délestages,
des coupures et cetera. Bon, certes,
c'est un drame pour les petits bobos
français qui euh ne sont pas
aussi un drame sur les populations
locales en Afrique, hein.
Non, mais mais en Afrique euh le
problème c'est qu'il y a pas que que moi
lorsque j'étais au Tchad au départ euh
il y avait euh 90 % de d'électricité pas
tous les jours et que maintenant vous y
allez, vous avez plus que 10 % hein,
vous avez 90 % de de moment délestage.
Par conséquent, on a augmenté le nombre
de petits moteurs diesel dans dans pour
les gens qui peuvent se le payer, hein.
Et puis les les gosses qui ont le
téléphone, ils recherchent est-ce que je
peux me recharger en électricité mon
portable partout ? puisque chacun a un
ou deux un ou deux téléphones portables.
C'est un donc c'est c'est ça le sujet du
délestage est un sujet très parisien euh
très
les gens les coupures d'électricité euh
chez moi en Bretagne on en a quand même
souvent. Euh
c'est quoi 2 minutes
quoi ? Ah non plus que ça.
Combien de temps
que ça ? une ou 2 heures. Une 2 heure.
Oui, bien sûr. Moi, il y a il y a des
tas et et même enfin je me souviens d'un
d'un d'une coupe d'électricité il y a il
y a 4 5 ans où euh sur l'ensemble de de
du village où je suis euh à cause de
tempête euh bon, il a fallu euh manger
tout ce qu' avait dans le congélateur.
Donc voilà, parce que c'est c'était
fini. Donc revenons à l'Allemagne.
Alors
donc l'Allemagne se retrouve un petit
peu dans la panade euh
qu'elle s'est construite. C'est ça que
je voulais dire qu'elle s'est
construite.
Bah elle a accepté l'énergie bon marché.
C'est c'est la technique du dealer.
Et elle a refusé le nucléaire.
Ah oui non mais ça Ah
oui. Ah oui bah c'est parce qu'elle a
refusé le nucléaire qu'elle dans la
panade. Si elle avait gardé centrale
nucléaire, c'est pas dans la panade.
Et donc là elle se retrouve dans la
panade parce qu'elle a pas de nucléaire
parce que le dealer a dit maintenant on
fait la guerre donc c'est compliqué pour
des questions de valeur.
Et elle a pas de terminaux de
décompression pour le gaz de chiste.
Donc là elle court elle court elle court
elle court pour faire ses terminaux.
Si on calcule
termina termina
sur bateau sur sur bateau c'est ça
provisoire ouisoire toujours tout
possible oui
ça coûte plus cher mais bon
mais avec quelle capacité de
très faible
que que chi c'est quoi c'est 20 % elle
va réussir
donc elle irait plus vite à à faire du
gaz de chiste allemand parce qu'il y a
du gaz de chiste en Allemagne et donc en
18 mois elle aurait du gaz de chiste.
Voilà, c'est puisquelle veut du gaz,
autant autant aller prendre son gaz de
chiste.
Ça risque de pas très bien passer quand
même.
Non, mais c'est les verres qui ont
refusé d'avoir les terminaux gaziers.
Mais non, c'est les verres aussi ont
fait des bones bonnes choses. Regardez
le gaz de chis aux États-Unis. La
déplion du gaz de chiste est importante.
Sont obligés de faire des petits trous
comme dans la viande pour l'attendrir un
peu partout. Fini ça.
C'est fini ça.
C'est fini ça. C'est on a fait des
progrès considérables. Non, non, vous
retardez là. Ah non, mais racontez-moi.
Est-ce que vous voulez me faire un petit
dire, je veux dire qu'avant là où on
faisait 30 40 puits euh on a on en fait
plus qu'un. Non non, c'est on a fait des
progrès considérables là-dessus. Alors
ce qu'on a par contre le le problème
qu'on a toujours hein, c'est c'est euh
celui de de l'injection hein, de
l'injection de l'injection d'eau. C'est
pas que d'eau hein, tout ce qu'on veut.
de l'eau donc c'est c'est ce problème là
qui qui est qui est toujours qui est est
toujours là. Donc moi je considère que
euh on obéit aux règles et que par
conséquent s'il y a des règles qui nous
disent qu'on peut ben on peut et si on
on on Mais il faut bien on peut pas dire
telle technique est une technique que
qu'on jette. Il faut dire voilà les
conditions dans lesquelles vous utilisez
donc le charbon. Voilà dans les les
le charbon. Voilà les conditions dans
laquelles vousz le pédrole et ainsi de
suite. Moi, je suis pour dire euh
débrouillez-vous mais euh vous devez
arriver à tel résultat et plutôt que de
dire l'éolien c'est magnifique, le solur
c'est magnifique, le machin non je
j'admets pas qu'on que qu'on jette
l'anathème sur des techniques. Je pense
que ça c'est un monde antiscientifique
ascientifique et qui et qui n'existe que
dans les romans feuilletons de je dirais
pas qui. Voilà.
L'industrie européenne vous l'avez vous
la voyez comment ? Sur le gaz russe ?
L'industrie automobile, l'industrie de
l'acier, l'industrie de l'aluminium,
l'industrie du verre, tout ce qui est
consommateur.
L'industrie européenne est une industrie
ultra spécialisée, donc ultra
consommatrice d'énergie. Quand on on
enlève 40 % de son apport énergétique,
qu'est-ce qui se passe ? On se tape une
résolution de 40 points, qu'est-ce qui
se passe ? Il reste plus grand chose.
C'est que c'est c'està-dire que
c'estàdire que non, soyons clair, la
civilisation dans laquelle nous sommes,
elle est bâtie sur
trois produits essentiels qui sont le
ciment, l'acier et le plastique. Vous
enlevez ça, il reste plus grandchose
dans cette pièce. En tous les cas, ça
s'effondre et on est on est dehors. Bon,
donc c'est ça le sujet et ce sujet-là
alors quand quand j'ai vu les les écolos
qui sont partis à l'assaut de la
cimenterie la phare, j'ai dit alors
ceuxlà c vraiment ils ont rien compris
mais si on rien compris c'est qu'onara
rien dit parce que sur 200 individus il
y en a bien un qui devrait comprendre ce
ce que je vais raconter. Donc il y a
trois produits résidentiels. C'est
énergétior. Ces produits résels doivent
être fait chez nous pour des raisons
d'Interland. Parce qu'autrement si
jamais euh on on n' pas ces produits de
base euh on est on n'est pas on n'est
plus capable de rien faire euh sur
place. C'estàd que toutes les autres
industries disparaissent. Donc euh il
faut arriver à à garder ces produits.
C'est ce que pensent les Allemands et
c'est ce
sont les industriel allemands. Par
conséquent, les industriels allemands,
on dit un, il faut qu'on ait le maximum
de gaz partout mais on sait qu'on l'aura
pas tout de suite. Bon donc on va
essayer de le prendre aux français ce
qui prennent actuellement hein. Donc si
jamais nous n'aurons n'avons pas assez
de gaz, c'est parce que nous l'aurons
cédé. Je dis pas vendu parce que
j'allais pas comprendre quel prix on
cédé aux Allemands, mais surtout parce
que les Allemands se sont aperçus que le
pétrole par contre sur un marché mondial
était était disponible, que les
raffineries finalement fonctionnaient
pas si mal même si on oublie les
réfineries russes et par conséquent on
fait le plein de gasol et donc ils ont
et ils peuvent transformer une partie de
leur de leur de leur pour de gaz en
gazole, c'est possible.
C'est ça coûte pas très cher. Donc c'est
ça qu'ils sont en train de faire
actuellement sur la plupart. Donc vous
vous voyez Duralex qui dit "Bon, je peux
je peux rien faire, je ferme
parce que ils ont pas dit je transfonds
du gaz en gazol. Mais si jamais les
vereries
allemandes ne disent pas en ferme, c'est
que elles ont fait le switch." OK. Bon
donc c'est la la situation énergétique
est fluide au point où on peut
transformer de l'un à l'autre du charbon
au gazol et cetera en oubliant
effectivement l'objectif de
déaronisation l'objectif climat. Donc la
seule manière de faire euh aujourd'hui
euh c'est dire bon euh on avait des
ambitions importante sur la euh sur le
climat sur
pour vous le réchauffement climatique
attendra. C'est sauvons d'abord les
boîtes et ensuite on sauvera la planète.
C'est c'estàd qu'
c'est je ne pense pas que nous allons je
ne pense pas que l'homme va sauver la
planète voyez. Je ne pense pas que je
pense
c'est sûr que si on fait ça ça va être
compliqué. Non, je pense pas que l'homme
bon l'homme est passé dans depuis mon
enfant jusqu'à maintenant de 3 à 8
milliards.
Bon donc le fait que la démographie est
est est augmentée de façon forte,
c'est grâce au pétrole, aux énergies
fossiles.
Voilà. Exactement. Bon, donc euh euh
je pense qu'il va avoir du le il va y
avoir du mal à passer de euh
milliards à 10 milliards en considérant
que l'ensemble du dispositif énergétique
va être modifié de façon considérable
par rapport à au-delà de 80 % en
fossile, charbon,
charbon,
pétrole et gaz.
Et quand il y a une crise et on voit la
crise là, on voit que on voit qu'on
oublie la décation, on l'oublie pas dans
le discours. Dire on continue à dévocar
mais c'est pas vrai. C'està-dire que
lorsque on on demande aux industriels
français euh est-ce que vous voulez un
peu d'argent et vous allez décarboner
les 10 sites industriels importants ?
Euh les industriels répondent oui. Et
qu'est-ce qu'ils font le lendemain ?
Vous savez su ce qu'ils font le
lendemain ? Ben ils enlèvent un ou de
four. Et donc ils ont décarboné.
Ah bon ? Mais mais parce qu'on le met
ailleurs. Donc donc ça c'est qu'on
décarbone la France ne décarbone pas la
planète. Il faut un peu de temps en
temps et c'est pas parce que j'enlève
une voiture à Paris que je sauve la
planète. Donc il faut un peu de un peu
un peu moins d'arrogance un peu moins
d'arrogance serait quand même
nécessaire. Bon, donc le sujet pour moi
c'est beaucoup plus de savoir si je peux
sauver une industrie, une des
technologies qui vont permettre de
trouver des solutions ou si je veux la
décroissance à tout prix et me suicider.
C'est
la décroissance, c'est pas suicider,
c'est éviter de se faire suicider par le
climat.
Non non, non, c'est suicider. C'est on
suicide d'abord. Non non, on suicide
d'abord. Il y a pas l'urgence climatique
que que vous indiquez n'est et il y a un
réchauffement climatique.
C'est clair.
L'urgence climatique,
moi je ne la vois pas comme elle est
elle est développée. Je ne la vois pas
mais bon j'ai
Est-ce que je peux est-ce que je peux
vous taquiner un peu ?
D vous avez bien sûr vous me taquinez.
Vous avez raison. En plus, en plus, en
plus, je sais que je sais que quand si
jamais je je dis trop ça euh dans
certains endroits, je je disparaît euh
de la planète média. Mais mais c'est pas
grave. Allons-y.
Qu'est-ce qui se passe euh quand on a un
taux d'humidité supérieur à 90 % et avec
des températures caniculaires pour
l'homme sans climatisation, sans grotte,
sans sans sans rien ? On canne.
On canne. Qu'est-ce qui se passe si en
Asie
qui ont un taux d'humidité au plafond,
on augmente la température ? On se
retrouve avec des milliards de personnes
exposé à un risque létal.
Donc ces gens-là, ces gens-là,
je j'ai j'ai bien j'ai bien compris
votre argumentation. Je pense avoir
compris votre argumentation. OK. Et
alors, je vais prendre une argumentation
différente.
C'est pour ça qu'on est là.
C'est pour ça qu'on est là. Voilà.
Alors, je dis la seule chance, l'homme
est adaptable. Il s'est adapté tout au
long de la
Mais à quel prix ?
L'homme est adaptable et il s'est adapté
à tout depuis qu'il est sur terre. Il s
adopté les glaciation
dans le temps.
Il y a eu réchauffement climatique avant
euh avant nous.
Pas pas le réchauffement climatique que
nous on a créé. On a eu le réchauffement
climatique par par les volcans. Vous
vous ne savez pas. Vous ne savez pas. Si
jamais vous arrivez à me déterminer
quelque part
la relation de causalité,
il faut lire logique.
La relation. Non non, il faut pas lire
le JC. Moi j'ai moi c'est moi ce qui
m'intéresse le JCn
pour faire un travail qu'ils font très
bien et qui dit voilà les ce que vous
faites. Bon OK très bien. Est-ce que
l'ensemble du monde scientifique auquel
j'appartiens est profondément d'accord
avec tout ce qui est fait ?
La réponse est non.
Bon la réponse est non. Bon, donc dans
les euh dans la science, on distingue la
corrélation et la causalité.
La corrélation, c'est deux phénomènes
apparaissent de façon régulière et de
façon donc vraisembablement il y a un
sujet
en la matière. La raison de causalité
c'est j'ai trouvé la raison pour
laquelle
ça ne ça ne va pas et par conséquent je
change. Aujourd'hui nous sommes en
relation de corrélation. Clair
corrélation.
Alors est-ce que c'est le nombre ?
Est-ce que c'est ce que nous faisons ?
Est-ce que c'est il y a une relation de
corrélation ? Mais il y a pas de
relation de causalité. C'est je suis
incapable aujourd'hui de dire voilà ce
que je vais faire qui va avoir telle
conséquence.
Je suis incapable de le dire. C'estàd
que ce que vous faites, ce qu'on fait
aujourd'hui en France en disant on va
décarbonner, on va faire si on reste, je
suis incapable incapable de chiffrer
quelle a l'influence sur le sujet sur la
corrélation que j'ai observé. Donc donc
vous n'iez pas le réchauffement
climatique.
Non.
Du dû à not activité industrielle.
D'accord. Je dis simplement Je dis
simplement que je ne sais pas
quelle est
les actions à entreprendre
les actions entreprend ce que je sais
par contre si
ce que je sais par contre c'est que si
jamais je fais disparaître comme
dans le le chiffre project de façon très
rapide
de chiffre de Jean Kevici
le charbon le gaz et le pétrole et
je fais disparaître l'industrie, je fais
disparaître la technique, je fais
disparaître les chances de m'en sortir,
c'est-à-dire la chance de m'en sortir,
c'est de voir quel est le système
d'adaptation de l'homme à aux
transformations, ce qu'il faut que je
fasse pour éviter un certain nombre de
péril et comment je vais comment je vais
y arriver. C'est grâce à la technique,
c'est grâce à l'industrie, à la science
que je vais réussir que je réussir à
faire ça. Et pendant ce temps-là,
qu'est-ce que je peux faire ? Je dis moi
je je dis pas il faut éradiquer
contrairement à à d'autres, je suis
désolé, j'ai pas la même réponse. Je dis
qu'il faut augmenter les rendements pour
et diminuer le gaspillage. Augmenter les
rendements, c'estàd que tout changement
d'état conduit à une baisse de
rendement.
Et et donc euh par exemple
l'idée
de dire je fais de l'éolien mais
j'utilise pas tout le temps l'énergie
parce qu'il y en a trop. Par conséquent,
je vais faire de l'électrolyse puis je
vais prendre l'hydrogène et je vais
utiliser cette idéel qui traîne un peu
partout c'est une idée stupide
pour vous
non ? Du point de vue du rendement, tant
que vous n'avez pas intégré la planète
Mars ou Uranus et où le rendement
vraisemblablement n'existe pas, tant que
vous êtes sur la terre et que vous dites
"Je sauve la planète, je parle de la
planète, je regarde le rendement." Et le
rendement est était quelque chose de
fondamental. De fondamental, c'està dire
que je peux pas transformer
euh une situation à 100 %. Je transforme
toujours en perdant un peu. C'estd que
c'est la perte, la perte de c, la perte
de ça. Et l'endroit où je perds le plus,
c'est transformation énergétique. J'ai
du mal à arriver à des rendements
satisfaisants. Donc la recherche par
exemple de diminution des des
difficultés du charbon, c'est une
recherche de d'amélioration des
rendements et on amélioré les rendements
en augmentant les températures, en
diminuant, on a diminué les émissions,
en faisant un de choses, on a changé les
matériaux de manière à ce que les
matériaux supportent les températures
plus importantes et donc on a on a fait
des travaux permettant d'arriver
d'arriver à ça. Je dis que c'est ça le
travail le plus urgent aujourd'hui,
c'est d'améliorer les rendements.
Alors alors en particulier lorsqu'on est
sur les batteries
et qu'on dit la solution pour la
mobilité c'est la batterie, on retombe
sur ce problème. C'est-à-dire que vous
avez des gens qui continuent à parler du
stockage électrique alors queon stock
l'électricité. C'estàd que c'est passé
dans le dans le dans dans dans le verbe
verbalement on dit le stockage
électrique. Bon ça inexact hein. C'est
c'est inex on stock pas l'électricité,
on stock pas le mouvement. Donc on a
l'électricité qui arrive, des électrons
qui arrivent. Bon et puis il y a un
produit qui est là qui change qui
change. Puis ce produit il est là, il
est il est d'une façon chargé avec
quelque chose. Il a changé d'état et ce
produit va au moment où vous lui
demandez va va renvoyer un certain
nombre de choses. Mais ils vont pas les
mêmes électrons. C'est pas les électrons
qu'il a pris qui vont partir, c'est
d'autres électrons qu'il va émettre.
Donc il a changé d'état et ce rendement
est épouvantable. Donc lorsque monsieur
Elon Mux dit "Je vais mettre des
batteries en en Australie parce qu'il y
a du territoire et cetera, il fait un
régiment de batterie énorme hein et puis
il met un peu de dents et puis quand ils
veut en sortir, il s'aperçoit qu'il a
chouilla. Bah oui. Bah oui parce que
c'est effectivement le rendement est
mauvais. Donc le le le travail qu'il y a
à faire aujourd'hui, c'est celui sur les
rendements et sur le fait que oui, nous
sommes avec le charbon, le pétrole et le
gaz qu'on va revenir pendant un certain
temps que tant qu'on a'ura pas vraiment
trouvé quelque chose euh de avec les
neutrons rapides euh demain, j'espère et
et d'autres et d'autres choses qu'on
peut trouver très bien. Il il y a
énormément de recherches partout dans
tous les sens. Je pense que c'est que je
pense que c'est ça, mais je vous laisse
parler. Vous vous avez compris mon
raisonnement hein qui est qui est
différent de celui que vous entendez
partout. Je reconnais. Enfin, c'est mais
c'est le vieux crab qui parle que vous
voulez comme ça.
Bon, on va on va taquiner le vieux
crabe. Alors, le vieux pirate. Euh
on se on se retrouve maintenant
avec
probablement une nécessité de changer de
paradigme, peut-être changer de
mentalité.
notre société d'hyperconsommation que
vous
avez vous avez initié, connu, entretenu,
peut-être que c'est peut-être pas ça le
infini.
C'est sûrement pas ça.
C'est sûrement pas ça. Pourquoi
continuer ? C'est mais c'est sûrement
pas ça. C'est sûrement pas ça. On change
de paradigme mais on est on a fait des
évolutions considérables sur l'industrie
et sur
on a fait des dégâts considérables.
On a fait des évolutions considérables
en 20 ans. On a transformé famine.
D'accord.
On a transformé on a transformé notre
appareil industriel. Je voudrais je
voudrais que que vous regardiez de temps
en temps l'intérieur de l'industrie pour
voir comment les les a trouvé sont
considérables. Bon, on a on a diminué
les émissions, on a surveillé, on a fait
un travail considérable. Bon et euh et
l'essentiel aujourd'hui, c'est de se
dire que il faut absolument augmenter
les circuits courts, il faut recycler
et il faut euh et il faut éviter les
gaspillages et on est et
vraisemblablement
tout ce qui a été imaginé avec les
produits à à qui étaient jetable
est un est un truc dont il faut mesurer
un peu mieux les les conséquences.
C'estàd que mais les premiers à vouloir
jeter leur téléphone et prendre un
nouveau, c'est les jeunes qui ont envie
que on change de civilisation. hein, il
faut faire attention, hein. C'est
c'est-à-dire que et mais
vraisemblablement
euh il y a là euh quelque chose qu'on a
euh où on a euh on a été euh euh on a
été trop loin euh dans euh l'idée que on
pouvait toujours trouver rapidement
mieux.
Est-ce qu'on a pas mis trop de conneries
dans la tête des jeunes ?
L'hyperconsommation le plus ça se
consomme à futilité. surtout mis
aujourd'hui comme connerie le fait que
ils peuvent changer
immédiatement de civilisation grâce à
l'éolien le solaire. Alors ça c'est une
connerie qu'on a mis dans la tête des
jeunes et qui nous coûte très cher
aujourd'hui hein. C'estàd que moi les
les publicités où on voit l'éolienne qui
tourne avec le petit enfant qui est là
et qui est dans la voiture électrique et
qui dit "Ah comme c'est merveilleux,
c'est silencieux, c'est merveilleux et
ça marche à l'éolien." J'entends encore
un ministre de de de l'environnement
dire moi je ma voiture marche à
électricité à éolienne. Donc je dire que
on a on a mis on a mis beaucoup de
bêtises dans la tête des dans la tête
d'og gam et et moi je sais que
mes mes petits enfants qui ont mon nom
doivent essayer d'éviter de de dire que
je un je soutiens le nucléaire et que
deux je suis un pétrolier. C'est c'est
pas très grave. J'ai beaucoup de dans de
de collaborateurs qui me disent "Bon ben
moi, j'essaie de je demande à mes
enfants de cacher quel est mon métier."
Donc oui, on a mis on a mis beaucoup de
beaucoup de bêtises dans la tête des
gens. Moi, pour moi, l'éolien n'est pas
écologique, hein. Je alors je reprends
parce que vous m'avez couvé tout à
l'heure, je reprends sur l'éolien un un
petit moment. C'estàd que il y avait un
sujet où on était d'accord tous en 73,
c'est que l'éolien n'était pas la
solution. Pourquoi ? Parce que c'était
intermittent les intermittents
irréguliers. C'estàd que l'intermittent
solaire,
on peut encore le régler puisquon sait
tous les tous les tous les jours que il
va avoir la nuit. Par contre, le vent,
on sait pas. Bon, et et que tout ce qui
est intermittent dérègle l'ensemble de
de l'électricité puisque l'électricité,
c'est un mouvement et c'est à chaque
fois que je produis, je dois consommer.
À chaque fois que je consomme, on doit
produire le correspondant. Donc il faut
il y a un équilibre toujours entre la
production et la consommation.
conséquent à chaque fois que je suis
intermittent je suis intermittent
multicyclique euh il y a pas alors seul
le seul non intermittence de du du de
l'éolien c'est quand on a froid c'est
d'entre le le mois d'hiver ou le mois
d'hiver il il y a en Europe il y a il y
a pas de il y a il y a pas de vent alors
ça c'est c'est le là on est tranquille
on peut faire le reste mais autrement
c'est toujours intermittent et dans la
mesure où lorsque vous avez un vent trop
faible ça sert à rien puisque vous Vous
êtes au cube de la vitesse avec le
les pâles et quand vous avez un vent
trop fort, vous arrêtez parce que les
pâles les pesent. Donc vous voyez donc
il y avait un sujet on disait où
l'éolien c'est vraiment dans des cas
particuliers euh et vraisablement euh en
en en mélangeant avec autre chose et
c'est clair les
lesoliennes verticales c'est pas mieux
pardon
lesoliennes qui tournent comme ça
vertical c'est pas mieux que lesoliennes
avec les grandes panes
a priori oui. A priori oui. Mais mais
mais de toute façon ça le même
inconvénient ça ça pas le même
inconvénient sur les oiseaux, sur les
chauves-souris, sur la biodiversité
hein. Puisque faut quand même faut quand
même pas oublier que lorsque vous signez
un contrat d'éolien, vous vous avez un
examen et on vous dit vous voilà les
espèces qui vont disparaître et et vous
êtes c'est accepté. Ouais, vous pouvez
aller voir le le contrat d'Hibberdrola à
Herky qu'aprel il y a 15 espèces qui
disparaissent. Bon, on dit vous êtes
autorisé à ça signer machine truc hein.
Donc voilà, c'est la réalité. Bon, alors
de toute évidence les les lesoliens
comme ça, les comme ça, comme vous dites
et est et est à l'égard de la
biodiversité plus intelligent. Alors
maintenant, on me dit le rendement est
encore meilleur parce que chaque chaque
hellisse enf pas je comment on appelle
ça des des des petits des petits objets
réagissent l'un sur l'autre et
entraînent l'autre. Bon mais on n'est
pas arrivé à l'optimum éolien de toute
façon avec les pes à 260 m c'est c'est
c'est un c'est un système qui n'est qui
n'est pas le bon mais en tout état de
cause l'éolien n'est pas un système euh
qui satisface aux besoins de la
population parce que
au besoin de notre modèle de
consommation
quoi
au besoin de notre modèle actuel
je
au modèle de consommation c'estd si
jamais Vous acceptez de dire j'ai je
regarde le match de football lorsque il
y a du vent et autrement bah il faut pas
que j'y joue au football parce qu'il y a
pas de vent. Moi je veux bien mais il y
a il y a bien sûr pour moi qui suis
africain voyez et bien lorsque lorsqu'il
y a lorsqu'il y a un match de football
et qui et et qui a pas l'électricité
c'est la drame. Donc on prend le petit
générateur on le met au centre du
village on met la télévision et on fait
marcher pour voir le le match de
football.
Sautons du cocalan.
C'est quoi l'arène ? La comment on
prononce ? Alors la reine c'est c'est
le le moyen qu'a eu. Alors il s'est
passé quelque chose de de bon le marché
d'électricité
a été créé pour la première fois au
Chili après Pinochet par la
le groupe de Chicago. Le groupe C, c'est
c'était des intellectuels économistes
libéraux américains qui considéraient
que si jamais le Chili était parti dans
les dans les l'atmosphère gauchiste,
c'était parce que on avait pas travaillé
correctement sur l'énergie qu'il fallait
en conséquence
retrouver la libéralisation. Donc ils
ont euh ils ont dit il faut qu'il y ait
un marché électricité
à l'époque. Euh
je j'ai toujours dit la même chose à
savoir que il y avait pas de marché
d'électricité possible hein. Donc je je
suis constant sur euh alors on peut me
traiter d'antilibéral, je me considère
libéral mais en économie mais il se
trouve que sur ce l'électricité de la
même façon que il n'y a pas de marché du
transport ferroviaire. Donc c'est c'est
ma position. Elle n'a pas varié non
plus. J'étais prf. Bon alors sur ensuite
il était en Argentine avec le succès que
l'on sait sur les deux pays, n'est-ce
pas ? Et ils sont retournés voir madame
Tatcher en disant voilà la situation. Et
donc on s'est parti sur l'idée qu'il
fallait créer un marché.
Et on a saisi cette idée pour dire il y
a des gens qui ont des problèmes avec
l'électricité qui marche moins bien en
Europe. Ce qui marche bien c'est la
France. On va les
embêter
en leur disant qu'il y a un marché
d'électricité. Et donc il y a eu un
combat auquel j'ai participé en tant que
français. Moi, j'étais président de Gaz
de France contre l'ensemble de l'Europe,
la coalition et les Allemands et les
Anglais de l'époque pour créer un marché
d'électricité per INDEC cadaver. Il
fallait créer le marché de l'électricité
et on a combattu, on a combattu, on a
combattu. Mais pendant le même temps, on
considérait ici en France que l'EDF
était un état dans l'État et qu'il
fallait le tuer. Alors, on s dit quand
même, c'est une bonne occasion de le
tuer parce que ça permet de faire trois
compagnies
si jamais on suit les Allemands et les
et la commission, c'està-dire de créer
ce qui est aujourd'hui Nedis et ce qui
est aujourd'hui RTE, c'est-à-dire la
distribution d'un côté et transport de
l'autre. Donc, on fait ce qu'on appelait
l'unbilding de manière à euh dire il
peut y avoir d'autres producteurs
d'électricité et il faut qu'ils aient
euh la capacité d'aller vers euh des la
distribution et il faut qu'ils aient un
transporteur qui transporte quelle que
soit l'électricité qui est produite.
Effectivement, à l'époque, il y avait
d'autres producteurs d'électricité.
Euh, il y avait le producteur qui était
la SNCF qui avait une société
d'hydraulique, la SMH et puis il y avait
euh euh NJ qui avait des centrales euh
en Belgique. Et donc il y avait matière
à dire
après avoir vendu la SMH à NG à dire il
y a plusieurs producteurs
simplement
il y a quand même un producteur
important qui est ODF et par conséquent
ce producteur était tellement important
que on n'arrivait pas à créer de marché
à cause de EDF.
Bien.
Alors,
on a fait Power Next pour faire un
marché électricité. Et puis en 2010,
juste après le le
craque européen 2008, en 2010, la
Commission est arrivée en France en
disant voilà, puisque vous n'avez pas
voulu mettre EDF au piquet, et bien la
nous avons décidé que vous auriez une
amende et cette amende serait de 20
milliards.
Alors à l'époque
euh le président
n'était pas à 20 milliards près.
Aujourd'hui, on serait pas à 20
milliards près. À l'époque, on était on
était à 20 milliards près. Et il a dit
"Ben, quelle est la solution ?" Et la
solution quoi lui a proposé la
commission, c'est de consacrer une
partie de
la la production de DF 20 % pour la
donner à des fournisseurs
qui ne produisaient pas, qui ne
distribuaient pas, qui ne transportaient
pas à un prix coûtant pour qu'il crée
artificiellement un marché
d'électricité. C'est-à-dire qu'il se
présente euh au
euh euh aux industriels et aux
particuliers en disant voilà, j'ai de
l'électricité parce que j'achète de
l'électricité à EDF. Donc j'ai
l'électricité et je vous la fournis
et vous n'avez rien à changer puisque
CEDF qui l'a fourni qui l' qui l'a
produit, c'est
qui vous la distribue et c'est RTE qui
vous la transporte.
et c'est la rente. Donc les derniers
mots, c'est l'électricité
nucléaire
historique. C'estàd que il y a une
histoire, l'histoire de DF, cette
histoire est un PI. Nous allons la
traiter et nous allons d'abord prendre
20 % de célectricité. Nous allons donner
à des fournisseurs. Ces fournisseurs, ce
sont des parasites complets puisque ils
ne font rien, ils font rien d'autre que
de faire des achats à terme puis de
faire des des de remplir des contrats
puis de dire qu'ils fournissent mais ils
fournissent pas puisque ils n'ont pas
d'action. Donc il y a des fournisseurs.
Donc il y a eu 45 fournisseurs qui se
sont institués avec des noms variés et
qui ont manipé ces 20 % de l'arène,
c'estàdire de l'électricité.
produite par EDF, distribué par les
transporté par RTE et sur lequel ils
font des bénéfices. Donc il y a des gens
dont j'appelle que j'appelle des
parasites.
J'espère qu'il s'achète des Maserati
pour le prix parce que ce serait dommage
qu' tous des parasites.
C'est que des Ce ne sont que des
parasites. Je vois pas je vois pas
quelle action ils font.
Dites-moi, dites-moi quelle est l'action
véritable qu'il faut à part aller
démarcher disant mais je fais moins cher
que l'autre parce que je vais faire et
cetera. Vous allez des heures creus des
machta. Moi je suis un petit industriel
aujourd'hui. J'ai
des contrats
sur une de mes entreprises
où
je payais 20000 € l'année dernière. Je
vais payer 120000 € cette année.
Je vais OK. Et je suis content. Et je
suis content. Donc j'ai vu les
fournisseurs, il y en a cinq qui
arrivaient à peu près au même au même
niveau. Les autres étaient plus chers.
Donc ça puis j'en ai choisi un. J'ai
choisi EDF par
patriotisme
patriotisme. Et il se trouve que dans ce
contrat, si jamais je prends
des droits à Rennes, je paye plus cher
que si j'en prends pas.
Et donc depuis maintenant 2 mois, je
demande à toutes les autorités
françaises de m'expliquer pourquoi moi
petite industrielle, si jamais je prends
des droits à Rennes, je fais plus cher
que si j'en prends pas. Et si vous
trouvez à trouver l'explication, vous me
le dites parce que j'ai toujours pas
compris.
Alors une autre chose, pourquoi le prix
du gaz et le prix de l'électricité sont
corrélés ? parce que les Allemands qui
ont pris la main sur euh le marché de
l'électricité
euh se sont déplacés à l'bzig et euh
pour eux euh le gaz était euh était pas
cher et leur centrale à gaz était par
conséquent des centrales d'appoint qui
était qui s'amortissait relativement
rapidement pour la raison que je vous ai
indiqué, c'est-à-dire que leurs leurs
éoliennes c'était en fait des éoliennes
à gaz. Donc elles étaient c'est des
éoliennes éoliennes à gaz. Donc c'était
donc c'est du gaz gaz était amorti. Bon
là le gaz a augmenté par conséquent ils
ont diminué le leur leur gaz. Ils ont
augmenté le charbon parce que et donc
les centrales à gaz deviennent des
centrales les plus chères alors qu'elles
étaient les moins chères au départ. Et
donc la comme on est en coût marginal et
que ils ont indexé le prix électricité
sur le prix du gaz qui n'était pas cher
à l'époque russe en caricaturant là
maintenant en époque non russe le coût
marginal de la dernière du dernier
électron est le plus cher du monde
quasiment et c'est à partir de ce prix
que le prix de des pex la la l'organe
qui fixe le prix de l'électricité
travail et donc c'est ce et donc l'idée
c'était de décorrél on l'a dit au départ
c'est que c'est pas on napprend pas
aujourd'hui en décembre 2022 ce sujet on
a parce que il y a 2 ans et demi le prix
du gaz a commencé à augmenter le gaz
russe parce que les Américains
demandaient à ce que le gaz russe monte
pour que leur gaz de chiste soit
compétitif hein. Donc le gaz russe a
commencé à le gaz en en tant que tel a
augmenté il y a 2 ans et demi. Il y a 2
ans et demi les petits français dont je
suis ont dit il faudrait quand même
qu'on décorelle ce serait pas mal 2 ans
et demi. Bon dire bien sûr mais de quoi
vous parlez ?
les Portugais, les espagnols ont bien
compris. Et donc dès le départ de
l'affaire, comme il il nous avaient lu
et ils avaient bien entendu ce qu'il
disait, nous nous on est pratiquement
pas connecté, on a rien, on n pas de on
est nous on est des pauvres malheureux,
on est là, on est oubliez-nous,
oubliez-nous. Et ils ont ils ont été
acceptés. Mais nous un on est
interconnecté un peu plus fort et deux
surtout comme on a fait tout ce système
de maintenance de centrale qui a conduit
à ce que elle soit pas en peur
d'avoir un hiver difficile et d'avoir
besoin des centrales à gaz allemandes
pour donner l'électricité. Et donc et
donc on s'est coincé en disant monsieur
l'allemand est-ce que vous êtes d'accord
pour que on nous aussi on fasse à 115 et
on dit non et et dit qu'est-ce qu'on
fait et qu'est-ce qu'on fait ? On est là
et on sait et mais mais nous on va
crever et on va crever guéri si j'ai
bien compris hein. C'est comme comme
certains.
Bon, il y a Guillaume 1er qui vous fa
check qui vous dit "Le parc hydraulique
installé ne décroit pas depuis 15 ans."
Et il y a
Oui.
Veg
le parc installé ne il y avait 58
réacteurs. Il y en a
Non, le parc hydraulique.
Ah le parc. Si si si. Il il le le il y a
il y a il y a moi non ben ça alors là je
suis désolé autant autant autant sur les
grands barrage oui il ne il ne change
pas c'estàd avec les turbines autant le
fil de l'eau il il disparaît des
productions tous les jours. Non non, ça
alors là mauvaise mauvaise
euh
alors je je je lisque
je lis
je suis je suis sûr de moi parce que en
plus je suis interieur dans lisien et je
peux vous amener les gens sur les
barrages qui ont disparu pas les
barrages les centrales les centrales en
fil de l'eau qui ont disparu qui a
guonjour contrairement à ce que dit
l'invité la corosi son contrat a été
décté sur à à je recommence
ah aussi été détecté ailleurs oui
oui
oui bien sûr
sur le circuit principal.
Non.
R
non
donc je demande à ce que vous échangiez
ensuite à fa checker corrosion sous
contrainte ASN.fr ASN contrôle corrosion
sous contrainte allez vérifier ça.
Revenons à nos moutons. Qui c'est qui a
fait péter Norstream à votre avis ?
Je sais pas.
C'est Poutine qui voulait plus payer le
gaz du moins pour pas payer les amendes
s'il arrêtait de fournir le gaz. Non,
c'est qui est-ce qui passé c'est une
c'est une manipe c'est une manipe
politique de service.
Bon et euh
et et s'il y a des gens
qui n'avaient aucun intérêt à le faire
péter, c'est bien les Russes. Alors si
jamais les services russes ont fait
péter ça, c'est à l'insu du plein grré
de des dirigeants de russe parce que
c'est une connerie. Voilà tout tout ce
qu'on peut dire.
Mais c'est c'est les services et c'est
une connerie. Alors, quelle a été la
manière dont les services ont fait ça ?
Mais c'est les services. Maintenant, on
a
De quel pays à votre avis ? De quel pays
à votre avis ? Oh, je pense que c'est un
un pays occidental maintenant.
C'est pas les Portion.
C'est pas les Espagnols.
Faut faire me faire dire après on va me
faire dire vous m'avez dit attention pas
de diffamation. D'accord. Alors, je vais
pas commencer à vous dire c'est l'intel,
c'est un tel, c'est un tel. Bon, non,
disons que disons que l'hypothèse qui a
été soumise au départ et qu'on m'a
soumise au départ lorsque puisque
j'étais à une radio au moment où ça
s'est fait, on m'a dit qu'est-ce que
c'est ? Mais je vous ai amené pour ça.
Bon, moi je peux vous dire que ceux ne
sont pas des professionnels du pétrole
qui ont fait ça. Voilà, ça je peux vous
le dire. C'està dire que les produits de
pétrole sont c'est non non ne sont
incapables de faire un truc pareil. Donc
il y a eu des pens pétrole qui les ont
conseillé peut-être mais c'est pas
pétrole. Voilà petit et quand on posait
la question c'est bien sur les russes,
j'ai dit je vois pas pourquoi et je
continue à dire je vois pas pourquoi.
Alors mais ça peut être aussi des
services secrets russes con hein. Vous
savez ça existe hein. Bon il y a des
gens qui qui ont prennent des
initiatives en croyant bien faire des
problèmes ceuxlà.
Euh question qui n'est pas une Je
commence par un commentaire qui qui une
question
qui est suivi de deux questions
comme le dit Aurélien Barreau. Vous
connaissiez Aurélien Barreau ?
Je connais l'existence.
Un mec très intéressant je je vous le
conseille.
Oui. Non mais j'écoute de temps en
temps.
Il m'énerve un peu. Mais mais mais
pourquoi il s'énerve ?
Ça me manère de parler. Oh là mais je
vous dis ben vous je suis franc hein. Je
l'écoute pas avec plaisir
quoi. Heureusement que vous avez pas dit
qu'il vous énervait parce qu'il avait
les cheveux longs hein parce que sinon
ça allait mal se passer hein. Foutit.
D'accord.
Comme le dit Aurélien Barreot les
ingénieurs sont formatés pour répondre
au problèmes que l'on qu'on leur pose.
Mais ils sont incapables de questionner
l'élancé lui-même. Ce monsieur pense
notre monde industriel en terme de
solution industrielle. Mais a-t-il déjà
tenté sérieusement de penser à un monde
moderne sans industrie ? Ne
devrions-nous pas arrêter de compter sur
les ingénieurs pour résoudre nos
problèmes ? B si si vous je conseille à
ce monsieur d'arrêter d'utiliser le
ciment, l'acier et le plastique et il va
et c'est tout. Je dis voilà arrête
arrêtez arrêtez tout ce qui est tout ce
qui est par exemple plus vous habitez
plus votre maison même pas en bois en
bois vous êtes vous pouvez même pas
faire une maison en bois si vous avez
pas de ciment
on chanre on chanre
quoi
en chanre
vous pouvez pas
vous pouvez pas non alors là autant
autant euh je suis pour regarder
regarder tout ça et je regarde je
regarde profondément c'estàdire que je
je dis que je je
suis je regarde le le chambre, le lin,
l'orti, le mélange avec les plastiques,
les matériaux composites. Je je
travaille avec mon ami Pierre Schmidth
en Alsace sur le sujet. J'essaie de
faire de faire que des que le lin va
recommencer à être cultivé en Bretagne
près de chez moi et on est temps de
regarder avec des jeunes qui sont
arrivés comment euh le le filet et
puisque aujourd'hui on on a des cultures
de l'in France, vous savez et et
l'intégralité part en Chine pour
revenir. Donc donc notre sujet c'est
dire est-ce que on peut prendre le lin
et et faire les choses avec ça ? Oui, il
faut il faut changer. Oui, il faut
changer. Mais ça se changera avec des
ingénieurs contrairement à ce qu'il
pensent. Ça va pas se faire dans l'air
du temps. On va on va prendre les les
chèvres et on va de même comme ça. Un
certain moment quand les cheères sont
malades, faut les soigner hein. C'est
quelqu'un qui est agriculteur qui vous
le dit en l'occurrence. Moi
bon, vous avez fait un peu de tôle, non
?
Oui. Et alors ?
Ah,
vous avez fait de la tôle ? Pourquoi ?
C'est l'histoire ancienne.
C'est l'histoire ancienne. D'accord.
Alors si je son ancienne, j'ai pas envie
d'en parler parce que ça m'emmerde. Par
contre, si vous avez envie que je vous
parle de euh euh la prison, j'ai fait
deux livres sur la prison. Alors, vous
les lirez d'abord, hein. Donc euh et
puis euh euh et puis ensuite la le
dernier, c'est réformer la prison. Donc,
j'ai des idées sur le sur le sujet qui
sont pas entendu. Enfin bon, c'est c'est
pas grave.
C'est quoi vos idées ?
C'est pas grave.
C'est quoi vos idées sur la prison ? La
la prison c'est que c'est que tant qu'on
ne sait pas ce qu'on y fait ça peut pas
marcher. C'est que l'homme est fait de
telle façon qu'il faut savoir pourquoi
il est quelque part et et quelle est son
occupation à l'endroit où il est.
Je voudrais que vous me racontiez
votre première nuit en prison. Qu'est-ce
qui s'est passé dans votre tête ?
Qu'est-ce qui qu'est-ce que vous vous
rappelez ? Est-ce que Est-ce que j'ai
j'ai le droit de vous dire que j'ai pas
envie de vous raconter parce que parce
que je l'ai écrit
dans quel bouquin appelé comment le
bouquin
vous avez écrit vous avez décrit dans le
bouquin la votre première nu
absolument ça s'appelle ça s'appelle le
livre s'appelle un une prisonnier
ordinaire
quelles éditions cherche midi. là et le
second livre s'appelle Repenser la
prison. C'est c'est Yv Michalon. J'écris
deux livres. Je suis à la disposition
des de tout interviewers après la
lecture des livres
et et vous me reprenez là-dessus et une
là aujourd'hui aujourd'hui bien sûr vous
prenez au mot. Non mais
je vais lire je vais lire les deux
bouquins.
Oui.
Et je vais vous rappeler et on va
discuter.
Oui. Très bien. Avec plaisir. Avec
plaisir. Question.
Alors si jamais il est clair il est
clair que si jamais on fait quelque
chose sur le sujet on fait quelque chose
d'H 2h et cetera, je suis tout à fait
disposé. Mais comme ça
après avoir lu les bouquins. D'accord.
Donc quand mme j'ai fait un effort quand
même. Il y a pas grand monde qui euh
autre chose de votre point de vue,
est-ce qu'il faudrait qu'on balance plus
d'hommes politiques en tôle ? Non, ça
sert à rien parce qu'ils sauraient pas
ce qu'ils font. De toute façon, ils sont
ils sont innocents par nature. Donc ça
sert à rien.
C'est une blague ou quoi ?
Oui, mais oui, mais oui. Ils ont jamais
rien fait. Ils sont responsables de rien
jamais. Donc problème. Je vois pourquoi
des gens qui sont jamais responsables
pour aller pour aller en prison ils sont
ils sont responsables. Non
non non j'ai c'était parce que personne
personne ne faitime. Alors on met les
trucs j'ai je suis content de faire
fenim à moi non jamais non c'est c'est
qu'est-ce que vous voulez faire ?
Qu'est-ce que vous voulez faire ? Vous
avez envie de quoi dire
non ça sert à rien.
D'accord. Je veux trois bouquins qui ont
compté dans votre vie.
Trois bouquins
à qui ont compté dans votre vie.
Ah des bouquins des bouquin que j'ai lu.
Que vous avez lu.
Ah que j'ai lu. Que j'ai lu. Bon mais il
y a
il y a un bouquin qui s'appelle Picou
fils de son père.
Voilà
ce
pas d'une grande œuvre mais c'est
c'était le le
maire de Guingan, ma commune qui avait
écrit sa sa vie et c'était
c'est très juste sur la la vie de cette
période et
voilà. Et puis euh et puis autrement
les
livres qui ont qui ont le plus marqué,
c'est pour moi c'est la
l'ensemble des des livres de du siècle
des Lumières euh sur la liberté. Alors,
vous en avez une quantité c'estàd que
que pour moi le l'élément dominant euh
de la vie c'est la liberté de penser, la
liberté d'expression et la liberté tout
court. à partir du moment où et et et
donc la la période de où les
le siècle des lumières arrive en en
exprimant cette cette volonté de
liberté, j'ai dévoré ça une grande
partie de une grande partie de ma vie.
Je voudrais que vous me parliez de ça.
Bon, ça c'est un livre que qui qui
s'appelle Il faut pas se tromper. Et
d'ailleurs depuis le départ, je j'ai
essayé, c'est moi.
J'ai écrit ça en 2018 parce que je
chantais qu'on allait à la catastrophe
sur l'énergie et et je commence
l'énergie en disant moi là, il faut pas
se tromper. On va attendre à se tromper
et ça va être grave. On s'est pas trompé
seulement là-dessus d'ailleurs, mais
j'ai encore en 2018 et c'était un gripe
un livre prémonitoire. Alors après, j'en
ai écris d'autres, écrit trois ou quatre
autres mais je reviens à celui-là qui et
puis on voit bien c'est l'énergie qui
est c'est une petite petite ampoule
petite une petite ampoule qui est qui
est là hein. C'est une ampoule. Est-ce
que est-ce qu'elle va continuer ou pas ?
Est-ce qu'elle va continuer ou pas ? Bah
elle va pas continuer longtemps. Et et
c'est c'est ça le sujet. euh principal
du livre.
Je voudrais que vous ouvriez une page et
que vous nous lisiez quelques lignes.
Vous savez, il faut mes lunettes. Alors,
c'est ça 4 ans. C'est ça.
Oui, c'est ça. Et alors là, elles sont
elles sont par là. Mais
bon, laissez tomber, laissez tomber.
Alors, alors alors là, vous me prenez
Non, parce que si jamais il faut que là,
je vais passer pour encore plus que
enfin mais le chapitre 20 si vousz c'est
l'énergie, il faut pas se tromper. C'est
écrit en gros. Alors après c'est c'est
en moins gros hein l'affaiblissement
française au cours des dernières années.
Donc c'est donc on est on est dans ce
sujet. J'aiécris ça en 2018 en disant
attention il y a il y a un sujet
prenez-le en main et puis j'ai vu que
j'ai vu que c'était pas vraiment pris en
main. Et puis soudain en 2022 on dit il
faut réindustrialiser en coupant en
coupant le coup à tous les gens qui
utilisent l'énergie. Alors je dis mais
ça c'est contradictoire puisque c'est ce
que j'ai dit dans le livre. Alors,
j'aimerais bien que chacun lise le livre
pour s'apercevoir que parce que tout à
l'heure on dit l'ingénieur il comprend
rien, il prépare rien, il est nul là. Le
pauvre ingénieur que je suis, bon, il a
vu des choses, il a dit comment il faut
faire. Mais ça veut pas dire qu'il faut
continuer à faire ce qu'on fait hein,
c'est par rapport à la question. Mais
c'est pas n'importe il faut faire. C'est
qu'il faut considérer que l'ingénieur
est capable de vous dire voilà dans dans
des circonstances différentes, voilà ce
qu'il faudrait faire et c'est ce que les
ingénieurs qui travaillent avec moi font
toujours. On est là-dedans, très bien.
Mais si jamais on fait autre chose,
qu'est-ce qui se passe ? Et si jamais il
y a pas la machine ? Et si jamais et
c'est un exercice que les ingénieurs
font de façon régulière. Question du
butcher du boucher. On voudrait son
opinion sur le rapport entre le projet
Hercule et la gestion de la Smart Grid.
Ça vous parle ?
Oui.
Alors, les les réseaux intelligents euh
Smart Grids, c'est ça a été euh ça a été
développé par un centre de de compagnies
dont Alstom.
Euh et ceci euh
et donc euh les Alstom était dans les
trois quatre grands sur le sujet. Il
s'agit de voir comment
euh utiliser au mieux l'électronique
pour euh que les réseaux euh
fonctionnent et que chacun puisse être
toujours à l'optimum, hein. Donc c'est
euh et c'est compliqué. C'est compliqué
parce que
le l'électricité est complexe. La
rencontre des réseaux des réseaux de
à courant faible, c'està-dire ceux que
vous utilisez là et à courant fort,
c'estàdire les hautes tensions, c'est
jamais bon. On sait pas trop comment les
phénomènes euh existent. On a on a vu
lorsque il y a eu la Grande Panne SNCF
euh à Amion Parnas que c'était parce
qu'on c'était à cause de la proximité
des réseaux forts et des réseaux fobles
que euh que qu'il y a eu euh des qui a
eu des problèmes et qu'on et qu'on a mis
une semaine à trouver euh trouver ce qui
s'est passé parce qu'on avait ajouté
un un réseau et que on avait mal
imaginé la rencontre
dans l'air des réseaux faiv des des
réseaux
Donc euh donc ces systèmes sont centraux
pour euh le futur de notre de notre
électricité en France ou ailleurs et et
la et la et disons l'efficacité ou le
rendement maximal.
Et ceci a été vendu à général électrique
qui n'était pas au moment où on a vendu
Alstom, on a vendu touté
et on a vendu les Smart Gris. On a vendu
on les
se trouve que
d'après ce que ce que j'en sais, les les
gens électriques n'avaient pas envie de
s'occuper de ça et s'en sont mal
occupés. Par conséquent, les gens qui
sont encore dans cette société ont le
sentiment de de pas avoir été écouté sur
les possibilité de développement de
Parits.
Et donc
il s'agit d'une certaine façon d'un
démantellement d'une compétence
française
dans le par le fait que on a enlevé un
bout alors c'était pas un bout de ADF
hein mais c'est un bout de compétence
française qui a disparu. On a repris un
en principe un bout qui est les turbo
alternateurs pour le nucléaire qui était
chez Alstom qui passion qui sont
revenus. Rabel. Arabel, c'est ça. On
récupérou mais mais il reste Mais il
reste à à l'extérieur chez électrique,
il reste les Smart Grids, il reste les
turbines
hydrauliques où on était les meilleurs
mondiaux puisque c'était c'était les
turbines les meilleures en France était
faites par Nerpic contrefois Sogrea, là
où j'ai travaillé mais c'est pas pour
c'est pas pour ça que qu'elles sont
bonnes. et et ensuite
elles ont été absorbé par Alstom et
Alstom G électrique et puis tout le tout
tout le charbon parce que le charbon
aussi on était en train d'augmenter les
rendements et c'était fait par Astom
avec les matériaux qui tenaient des
températures importantes. Alors le
projet Hercule c'est un projet de
démantellement encore de DF et et donc
c'est encore un démantellement c'est pas
comment ça va ça va se dérouler quoi.
Donc c'est en ça que la question la
question se pose. C'estàd que on a
l'impression que les réformes du système
c'est le démantellement et et on voit
que le démantellement vient de faire
souffrir l'industrie française à un
point tel que finalement les
responsables
français des spart grises, on sait pas
trop où ils sont aujourd'hui. On on sait
pas trop ce qu'on veut en faire ni
général électrique ni les Français. Et
on dit est-ce qu'on va continuer avec le
projet Hercule qui est un projet de
démantellement ? On dit on va on va
mettre le nuc à côté, on va mettre
l'olide de l'autre, on va mettre est-ce
qu'on on met en bourse une partie. Tout
ça tout ça est est de l'angoisse pour
l'ensemble des ingénieurs de DF, de
l'angoisse pour l'ensemble des gens
comme moi qui regardons mon pays en
train de se déliter. Et je dit bon
essayons de conserver encore quelques
trucs qui marchent. Ne faisons pas
d'Hercule un démantellement nouveau
alors qu'on vient de démonter Alstom en
faisant des catastrophes.
Je voudrais que vous laissiez un conseil
pour les jeunes générations. Une
bouteille à la mer.
quelque chose d'impérissable qui restera
sur internet.
Bouteille à la mais
alors la première chose qui vient à
l'esprit n'ayez pas peur. Voilà. Alors
je reconnais je reconnais que c'est
embêtant parce que c'est Jean-Paul II
qui l'a dit et que ça paraît être faire
de moins un catholique ferrant. C'est
pas le sujet. Euh ma mère était une
grande une était très pieuse mais pas
moi. Mais mais j'ai dit je trouve que
que à l'heure actuelle on essaie de
faire peur aux jeunes surtout la planète
va s'effondrer, le euh la température va
augmenter vous mais il faut mettre des
il faut mettre des pantoufles, il faut
mettre des des pulls à col roulé, il
faut mettre des machins. Vous la
catastrophe par contre, faut pas
gaspiller. N'ayez pas peur. dire que la
technique, les les la l'intelligence,
les entreprises, une intelligence
collective est plus forte que les peurs
qu'on essaie de de de envoyer. C'estd
que si aujourd'hui par exemple
vous avez
le Covid a conduit à à ce qui s'est
passé, c'est-à-dire finalement nos nos
jeunes se sont trouvés sans école chez
eux à part de sortir
tout tout ça
c'est de la peur qu'on leur a donné
raison à peur
non à tort.
Pourquoi ? parce qu'ils étaient pas eux,
ils étaient ils étaient ils étaient
quasiment immunisés
les enfants. Quasiment quasiment
immunisés. Si si.
C'est quoi vos sources ?
Quoi ? C'est quoi vos sources ?
Quoi ? Les sources statistiques
statistiques de quoi ? Est-ce qu'il y a
des séquelles sur sur les sur les les
jeunes qui ont des Covid même à
symptomatique ? Vous avez creusé le
sujet ? Oui, mais je dis que c'est c'est
ce qui est arrivé psychologiquement à
l'ensemble des enfants à la suite de ça
est bien plus important de mon point de
vue. Non, mais chacun son point de vue.
C'est le vôtre. Le c'est
non mais je je suis je suis je suis un
vieux scientifique hein. Donc mon
origine, je suis le seul
je suis je suis non mais je suis c'est à
la délégation générale recherch
scientifique et technique pendant 12
ans. Donc j'ai j'ai vécu dans le monde
scientifique pendant 12 ans avec des
scientifiques avec des gens aujourd'hui
disparus. J'ai
donc je suis j'ai bon donc attention à
aller trop vite à la conclusion. Donc je
dis moi vous me donnez mon avis. Je dis
les jeunes on leur a fait peur à un
point trop élevé
trop élevé sur ce sujet comme sur les
autres. C'est que les jeunes qui sont en
train de se mettre sur le le la rue de
Rivoli pour arrêter les bus en se
mettant les mains par terre avec de la
colle en disant c'est pour sauver la
planète. J' dit non, vous vous avez
manqué un truc là.
Ouais, c'est peut-être un un
c'est la peur.
Non, c'est c'est peut-être une façon
d'alerter.
Non, mais ils alerte de quoi ? La peur
de quoi ? La peur quoi ? La pe la peur
pas le danger.
La peur d'avoir une baisse de rendement
parce qu'il y a impossible de cultiver.
La peur d'avoir la peur d'avoir des
millions de morts parce que ils sont nz
pas peur virgule n'ayez pas peur virgule
affronter le danger. Voilà. Est-ce que
ça vous plaît ? C'est ça, c'est ça on
affronte.
Il faut nous il y a des dangers, OK, on
affronte mais ça sert à rien d'avoir
peur de rien faire. Ça sert à rien de
coller ses mains sur le sur la rue de
Rivoli et pour dire euh attention
attention il y a urgence urg ça sert à
rien.
Et quand et quand il y a des
scientifiques euh qui prennent leur
blouses blanches et qui viennent euh râ
manifester et dire que ça fait 50 ans
qu'
des scientifiques
c'est la majorité quand même
on en sait rien. Non non s pas rien.
On savait rien. C'estàd que les
scientifiques d'une façon générale, je
les ai manipés pendant 12 ans et j'en
suis un donc voilà. Bon les
scientifiques inur climatologue.
Quoi ?
Vous êtes ingénieur pas climatologue ?
Je suis pas climatologue. Non non mais
j'ai je suis ingénieur je suis
biologiste de du son institute de stud à
San Diego. Ça vous plaît ? Voilà. Bon,
donc je je suis je suis ingénieur ayant
appartenu au monde scientifique pendant
12 ans profondément et je suis toujours
là-dedans. Et donc attention à ne pas
considérer que parce qu'il y a des gens
qui parlent
et qui
vous exposent quelque chose, ces gens-là
ont la science qui vous permet d'agir.
Ce n'est pas vrai. Il n'y a la science,
c'est essentiellement le doute
et donc je doute de tout. OK. Bon et
puis à certains moments, il faut que je
prenne une décision et je sais que cette
décision est basée sur un certain nombre
de choses qui sont insuffisantes pour
que je la prenne. Et je la prends quand
même.
Je prends quand même la décision parce
que il faut bien en prendre une vo et et
c'est en quoi il faut pas avoir peur et
il faut inventer le danger.
Vous avez vous avez lu le rapport du GC
bien sûr
en intégralité
quoi.
En intégralité
pas j'ai je je vais vous dire je vais
vous dire quelle est l'origine de ma
science sur le sujet. C'est-à-dire que
euh vous avez une revue qui s'appelle
science ou pseudoscience
avec des gens qui écrivent écrivent
depuis sans pcience.
C'est une revue mensuelle science ou
pseudoscience.
C'est une revue qui est rédigée par un
certain nombre de de types avec qui j'ai
travaillé ou j'aurais travaillé ou je c
et qui sont des scientifiques qui et qui
sont tous climatosceptiques dedans ou
pas du tout ?
Pardon ? Ils sont tous climatosceptiques
dans cette revue ou pas ?
Ah aucun
aucun.
Tout le monde tout le monde. Moi je suis
pas climatosceépique. Ah non non.
Attention attention. Non non là là
complètement idiot ce que vous dites
hein. Je suis pas en train de dire que
vous êtes climat
ces gens-là ces gens là décrivent
décrivent de manière scientifique de mon
point de vue euh la manière de lire le
rapport du GC, comment il a été élaboré,
quels sont les gens qui qui sont qui
sont contre que cetera et ils exposent
la vue. Donc le rapport n'est pas la
Bible, c'est un rapport fait par des
gens qui sont euh
sont persuadés de persuadés de de ce
qu'ils font mais qui ne sont pas
l'exposé de la science climatologique
mondiale. C'est pas vrai. C'est pas
vrai. Alors si vous lisez le livre de
d'Ivrocôte, vous apercevez que vous
appelz livre côte. Bon, côte c'est euh
c'est l'oscurantisme vert. C'estàd que
côte reprend un certain nombre de de
sujets et dit bon là on dit ça là on dit
ça. Mais le mieux pour moi c'est que
vous lisiez sciences et pseudoscience.
Il y a deux ou trois numéros sur le
sujet à chaque fois que le rapport du
JXOR il il le commente euh et d'accord
avec ils sont d'accord avec.
Il y a il y a pas un rapport du Jack.
C'est c'est là où c'est là où où
vraiment j'ai l'impression que vous
lisez pas le rapport du J. C'est que le
rapport du JC n'est pas un rapport.
C'est il y a il y a il y a il y a un a
il y a des études différentes, puis
ensuite il y a une synthèse, puis
ensuite il y a le un rapport pour les
gouvernants. Alors de de quoi vous
parlez ? Moi je moi je lis des gens qui
lisent les rapports qui me disent voilà
ce qu'il y a dedans et avec qui je
discute. C'estàd que je je reprends le
la terminologie.
Ils sont fiables ces gens-là
quoi.
Ils sont fiables.
Personne n'est fiable. Je doute tout le
temps.
C'est pas le sujet. Je je suis moi si si
vous lisez Ana a le concept de la
dispute. Je suis dans la dispute et je
suis dans la dispute permanente.
C'est-à-dire que c'estàdire que je ne
sais pas. Vous me dites "Je sais vous
savez. Moi je vous dis à ma connaissance
voilà où j'en suis. Maintenant est-ce
que je peux changer d'opinion ? Oui,
j'en ai d'opinion si jamais on me
démontre que je n'ai pas aujourd'hui
sur le le climat
le le concept d'urgence climatique,
c'est-à-dire
il va se passer des choses abominables
dans les 5 ans qui viennent. Non, je
suis pas d'accord. De la même façon que
il va quand même se passer des choses.
Il va se passer des choses mais pas des
choses abominables. Abominable. Vous
avez vu un flux de migrant sur 40° avec
95 % arrêtez de m'arrêter. De la même
façon que les journalistes m'ont m'ont
interroger sur Azaporidja les
soviétiques et enfin les pardon les
Russes et les Ukrainiens sont en train
de se battre exoviétique sur cette
centrale soviétique bien connue de
Zaporidja avec quatre réacteurs qui est
la plus grande centrale six réacteurs la
plus grande centrale d'Europe. Qu'est-ce
qui va se passer ? Il y a une bombe qui
tombe dessus. Qu'est-ce qui va se passer
?
Et quand j'aurais dit rien,
pourquoi rien ? Ça va exploser ? Dit
rien il se passe rien. Il va il va se
passer que sur un périmètre dont on sait
pas bien
qu'on sait pas bien mesurer 1 km 2 km,
il va y avoir une irradiation
importante. Donc il faudrait mieux que
les gens quittent cette ce périmètre et
puis voilà. Et puis voilà. Et puis voilà
l'irradiation l'irradiation qu'ils vont
avoir au bout de 2 km va être à peu près
celle que j'ai en tant que Breton sur ma
granite en Bretagne. C'est pas c'est pas
c'est pas sur Zapor. Je suis pas en
train de parler de la bombe je pas en
train de dire une bombe atomique tombe
sur pas ça. Je dis une tombe sur le
réacteur. Mon dieu c'est terrible comme
ça. Qu'est-ce qui se passe ? Pas
grandchose finalement. pas grand-chose
parce que il est arrêté, il est arrêteur
hein. Donc donc je crois qu'il faut
faire attention à ne pas à ne pas
considérer alors il y a des gens qui
étaient là sur le plateau qui ont dit
c'estux abominable et cetera. Il y a un
type qui a dit il y a avec après les
500000 morts de Ternobyl vous comprenez
que on a on a des raisons d'avoir peur.
Ah bon ? 500000 morts de Char où est-ce
qu'ils sont ? Combien de mort ?
Combien de morts ?
50 pompiers qui ont été tués par le feu.
Ensuite, il y a eu des gens qui ont été
irradiés. OK. Alors, on a étudié
des enfants aussi. Ouais. Des enfants.
Il y a eu des gens qui ont été. OK. Et
donc, on a il y a eu une étude sur 30
ans pour savoir ce qui s'est passé.
Alors, effectivement, une des actions
des irradiations, c'est le cancer de la
thyroïde.
Donc, regardez.
Et il a fallu l'OMS a travaillé pendant
30 ans sur le sujet pour voir s'il y
avait eu vraiment augmentation important
des cancer la thyroïde. Le rapport dit
grossièrement statistique.
On verra ça plus tard.
C'est c'est non c'est pas ça le rapport
qu'ils ont dit. Ils ont dit ils ont dit
grossièrement ça a diminué la vie de
4000 personnes de 8 mois. Voilà la
conclusion. Voilà. Bon, j'ai pas lu le
rapport. Pour synthétiser votre conseil
pour synthétiser le conseil aux jeunes
générations, c'est "N'ayez pas peur."
C'est ça. Reformulez-le.
N'ayez N'ayez pas peur. Qu'est-ce que
j'avais dit ? Pas peur.
Battez-vous.
Non, c'est euh affronter le danger.
Le flocant. Merci.
Je vous en prie.
[Musique]